This episode is supported by Anthropic, the team behind Claude. Now, history's biggest leaps started as hard questions that people didn't want asked. Yeah, there's a classic example of that at the end of the 15th century. And the hard question in particular was, what is out there beyond the Atlantic Ocean to the west? And as you will know, the man who found the answer to that question was the explorer Christopher Columbus. And he realizes, or rather everybody else realizes, that there is a vast continent out there. And it is, of course, the Americas. So Anthropic knows the importance of questions. And it's why Anthropic is founded on one hard question above all. How can we ensure that the AI revolution
本期节目由Claude背后的团队Anthropic赞助。历史上的重大飞跃，往往始于人们不愿触及的尖锐问题。在15世纪末，就有一个经典的例子。当时一个特别尖锐的问题是：大西洋以西究竟有什么？众所周知，找到这个答案的人是探险家克里斯托弗·哥伦布。他意识到，或者说其他人也意识到，那里有一片广阔的大陆。当然，那就是美洲。Anthropic深知提问的重要性，这也是Anthropic创立时最核心的一个尖锐问题：我们如何确保人工智能革命
really goes well for ordinary people? So they asked over 100,000 people and what came back wasn't just fear. There was hope as well. People wanted to know, will cancer ever be cured? It turns out that there is hope in hard questions. Ask yours at clodd.aI slash rest is history. And keep thinking. Let us be grave and discreet in all our deliberations as men who determine the interests of the world. Let us be ardent and tenacious in anger towards the leagues of tyranny, imperturbable in danger, patient in labour, terrible in adversity, modest and vigilant in success. Let us be generous towards the good, compassionate towards the unforestationate towards the unforeseen,
能真正造福普通人？于是他们询问了超过10万人的意见，得到的反馈不仅有恐惧，还有希望。人们想知道，癌症终有一天会被治愈吗？事实证明，尖锐的问题中蕴含着希望。请访问clodd.aI slash rest is history提出你的问题，并保持思考。让我们在所有的审议中保持庄重和谨慎，就像决定世界利益的人那样。让我们在面对暴政联盟时保持热忱和坚韧，在危险中保持镇定，在工作中保持耐心，在逆境中保持坚毅，在成功时保持谦逊和警惕。让我们对善良的人慷慨，对不幸的人富有同情心，对不可预见的事物，
fortunate, inexorable toward the wicked, just towards all. Let us not count on an unalloyed prosperity, nor on triumph without obstacles, nor on anything that depends on the fortune or perversity of others. We should rely solely on our own constancy and our own virtue alone. But infallible guarantors of our independence, let us crush the honourable. Holy League of Kings, even more by our greatness of character than by the force of our arms. So that was a speech given by Maximilian Robespierre on the 8th of June 1794 in the gardens of the Twilery in the centre of Paris. Now some people might find that stirring. Others might think
对幸运的人，对邪恶的人毫不留情，对所有人公正。让我们不要指望纯粹的繁荣，不要指望没有障碍的胜利，也不要指望任何依赖于他人命运或乖戾的事物。我们应该仅仅依靠我们自己的坚定和美德。作为我们独立的可靠保证，让我们以高尚的品格，而非武力，去粉碎那可耻的国王神圣同盟。这就是马克西米连·罗伯斯庇尔于1794年6月8日在巴黎市中心的杜伊勒里花园发表的演讲。有些人可能会觉得这很振奋人心。而另一些人可能会认为
is the kind of thing that the headmaster of a minor public school might say at the first assembly of term, or that a particularly weedy Church of England Bishop would say to his dwindling congregation. But actually in this case, the occasion was the strangest and most colourful public spectacle
这就像是一所小型公立学校的校长在学期第一次集会上会说的话，或者是一个唯唯诺诺的英国国教主教对日益减少的教众所说的话。但实际上，这次场合是整个法国大革命中
of the entire French revolution. That is saying something. So Tom, when and where and why are we? This is a festival in honour of the supreme being. So Rosspier had announced this deeply accent
最奇怪、最丰富多彩的公共奇观。这可真是不简单。那么，汤姆，我们现在身处何时、何地，又为何在此？这是一个纪念最高主宰的节日。所以罗伯斯庇尔宣布了这个深具意义的
public spectacle, a month earlier on the 7th of May. And it was a great festival to which literally everyone was invited. Robs-Pierre wanted it to be an occasion so civic that basically every citizen could turn up and enjoy the fun, enjoy the stirring oratory. And the whole occasion was very, very much his baby. He had gone to inordinate efforts to make it a success. And he had invested a lot of his political capital. in putting it on
公共奇观，就在一个月前的5月7日。这是一个盛大的节日，几乎邀请了所有人参加。罗伯斯庇尔希望这是一个如此具有公民意义的场合，以至于基本上每个公民都能到场享受乐趣，享受那振奋人心的演说。整个活动在很大程度上是他一手策划的。他为了使其成功付出了巨大的努力，并投入了大量的政治资本
because there's a fair degree of scepticism around it has to be said so not only had he had himself elected president of the national convention so basically the official government of France four days before this festival is staged so that he can play the kind of the constitutionally appointed central role
来举办它，因为必须说，周围存在着相当程度的怀疑。所以，他不仅在这次节日举办前四天让自己当选为国民公会主席，也就是法国的官方政府，这样他就可以扮演那种宪法规定的核心角色，
in the whole proceedings but he has also very thoughtfully had the guillotine moved from the Place de la Evolution, which is kind of just across the road, so that the sound of the blade slicing and the spurting of blood and the cheers of the crowd won't detract from the solemnity of this great event that he's planned. So very thoughtful. That's nice. And Robs Pierre has one of the great impresarios in all history at his side. And this is the painter Jacques Louis David, who we did a bonus about with Laura Cumming.
在整个过程中，他还非常体贴地将断头台从革命广场移走，因为那里就在马路对面，这样刀片切下的声音、喷溅的鲜血和人群的欢呼声就不会破坏他计划的这场盛大活动的庄严感。真是太体贴了。这很好。罗伯斯庇尔身边还有历史上最伟大的演出策划人之一。这就是画家雅克-路易·大卫，我们曾和劳拉·卡明一起做过关于他的特别节目。
Death of Mara. Yeah, exactly. prepared all kinds of extravagances for it. So he has a massive choir and when they're all put together, all these various choirs constitute 2,400 voices. So that's quite a volume. Incredible stage sets, brilliant special effects and some dazzling pyrotechnics. And he's also designed the costumes. He's hired florists with baskets to hand out flowers, fresh cut flowers. And he's got girls in white dresses
《马拉之死》。是的，正是如此。他为节日准备了各种奢华的布置。他有一个庞大的合唱团，当他们聚集在一起时，所有这些不同的合唱团总共有2400个声音。所以音量相当大。令人难以置信的舞台布景、精彩的特效和一些耀眼的烟火。他还设计了服装。他雇佣了带着篮子的花匠来分发鲜花，新鲜采摘的鲜花。他还让穿着白裙的女孩们
to hand them out from these baskets. So very, very kind of attractive. He's learned his lesson from Mara's funeral, which was the last great spectacle that he staged. So he doesn't have any rotting bodies or severed arms falling off or anything like that. No, but even so, even though
从这些篮子里分发鲜花。所以看起来非常非常吸引人。他从马拉的葬礼上吸取了教训，那是他策划的最后一场盛大奇观。所以他没有让任何腐烂的尸体或断肢掉落之类的东西出现。没有，但即便如此，尽管
he doesn't have any postule-ridden bodies, kind of threatening foul smells, he is nervous when the Great Day dawned. Much like a rest his history host who is staging a festival at Hampton Court Palace. But such a person be nervous, I don't believe they would. Maybe one of us was a little bit.
他没有那些长满脓疱的尸体，也没有那种令人作呕的恶臭，但在大喜之日黎明时分，他还是感到紧张。就像一位在汉普顿宫举办节日的《Rest is History》主持人一样。但这样的人会紧张吗？我不相信他们会。也许我们其中一个人会有一点。
But Robespierre, he's trying to get himself in the mood. He's trying to kind of pep himself up by looking at his absolute best. And of course, we've been talking throughout this series about how fastidious he is, how concerned about his appearance he is. And so he has put on his very best Republican finery. So he has an exquisite blue coat, which will. be featuring later in this series. He's wearing a trickleur sash. He's got a plumed hat. But unfortunately, he's so nervous that when he left the house of Maurice DuPlay, his landlord, he left behind a large
但罗伯斯庇尔，他试图让自己进入状态。他试图通过展现自己最好的一面来振奋精神。当然，我们在整个系列中一直在谈论他是多么挑剔，多么关心自己的外表。所以他穿上了他最好的共和党盛装。他有一件精致的蓝色外套，这件外套将在本系列的后面部分出现。他戴着三色饰带。他戴着一顶插着羽毛的帽子。但不幸的是，他太紧张了，以至于当他离开房东莫里斯·杜普莱的家时，他落下了一个巨大的
bouquet of flowers that had been made for him by one of the DuPlai daughters. So that's very sad. And the other indication of how nervous he is, his stomach is clearly so knotted up that he doesn't have breakfast and he has to be persuaded to go up and kind of pick him. it. So he is very anxious. He wants this day to be a massive success. But in the event, you know, he needn't have worried because everything goes brilliantly. Everybody absolutely loves it. Doesn't rain. Everyone has an absolutely lovely time. And the great thing, thousands upon thousands of patriotic citizens do flock to the tuileries to partake of the fun. Well, they love a public show. Yeah, there's a slightly Trump quality to the estimation of how
花束，那是杜普莱的女儿之一为他制作的。这太令人难过了。另一个表明他有多紧张的迹象是，他的胃显然紧绷得厉害，以至于他没吃早餐，还得被劝说去吃点东西。所以他非常焦虑。他希望这一天能取得巨大的成功。但事实上，你知道，他不必担心，因为一切都进行得非常顺利。每个人都非常喜欢它。没有下雨。每个人都度过了一段非常愉快的时光。最棒的是，成千上万的爱国公民确实涌向杜伊勒里宫参与其中。嗯，他们喜欢公共表演。是的，对于有多少人到场，这有点像特朗普式的估算。
many people turned up. So Robespier-a-Miris say that half a million are there. It's probably in exaggeration, but it's certainly, it's very, very enthusiastically attended. And the girls all look lovely in their beautiful white dresses. The flowers all smell gorgeous. It's great. Everyone has a fantastic time. Oh, sounds wonderful. And David's stuff goes off, passes off much better than at the funeral of Mara, presumably.
罗伯斯庇尔可能会说有五十万人到场。这可能是一种夸大，但确实有非常非常多的人热情参与。女孩们穿着漂亮的白裙子看起来都很可爱。花朵闻起来都很香。太棒了。每个人都度过了一段美妙的时光。哦，听起来太棒了。大卫的东西比马拉的葬礼上进行得好多了，大概是这样。
Yeah, brilliantly. So the morning's highlight, people gather around this enormous spectacle, and it's a large statue of a hideous figure with the ears of asses made entirely half. of cardboard, which I don't think sounds very impressive, but everyone is incredibly impressed by it. Maybe it's very thick cardboard. Robs-Pierre is there. He's looking very natty in his sash and his blue coat. And he appears in front of the crowds. He gives a speech, which again, we're told, goes down very well. But I suspect nobody can hear it. I mean, obviously there's no kind of amplification. I think this is the case with all open-air speeches before about 1950, isn't it?
是的，非常出色。所以早上的高潮，人们聚集在这个巨大的奇观周围，这是一个巨大的丑陋人物雕像，长着驴耳朵，完全是用硬纸板做的，我觉得这听起来并不令人印象深刻，但每个人都对它印象深刻。也许是纸板很厚。罗伯斯庇尔在那里。他穿着饰带和蓝色外套，看起来很时髦。他出现在人群面前。他发表了一次演讲，我们被告知，这次演讲效果很好。但我怀疑没人能听见。我的意思是，显然没有任何扩音设备。我想在1950年之前所有的露天演讲都是这样，不是吗？
I mean, the crowd loved it, but actually no one could tell what was being said. Maybe reports of it are being kind of funneled backwards through the crowd. I don't know. Anyway, then the excitement, he is presented with a torch, a flaming torch, and he sets fire to the cardboard figure. So it goes up in flames. And then from the flames, another cardboard statue emerges, and to quote Ruth Gere in her biography of Rosbier, this second cardboard statue was fair, majestic.
我的意思是，人群很喜欢它，但实际上没人能听清说了什么。也许关于它的报道是在人群中向后传递的。我不知道。总之，然后是激动人心的时刻，他被递过一支火炬，一支燃烧的火炬，他点燃了那个纸板人物。于是它燃起了火焰。然后从火焰中，另一个纸板雕像出现了，引用露丝·吉尔在罗伯斯庇尔传记中的话，这第二个纸板雕像庄严、宏伟，
and only slightly singed. And this matters because this is an allegorical pyrotechnic stunt. And obviously, if you're doing an allegorical pyrotechnic stunt, you don't want both of your statues going up in flames because it turns out that the statue with the ass's ear represents atheism. And the slightly singed figure that emerges from within it once it's been burnt is wisdom.
而且只有轻微的烧焦。这很重要，因为这是一个寓言式的烟火特技。显然，如果你在做一个寓言式的烟火特技，你肯定不希望你的两个雕像都烧成灰烬，因为事实证明，那个长着驴耳朵的雕像代表无神论。而当它被烧毁后，从里面出现的那个稍微烧焦的人物是智慧。
So if wisdom had gone up in flames as well as atheism, the whole point would have been lost. As it is, the watching crowds cheer and toss their liberty caps in the air and shout hurrah for Robespierre. Robs Pierre gives another speech, which again, I presume no one can hear. And then everyone joins in with a patriotic hymn, which has been composed especially for the occasion. So, I mean, the fun is limitless. And then that afternoon, there's another spectacle. And this takes place in the middle of the Champ de Mars, just down from where the Eiffel Tower
所以如果智慧和无神论一起烧成了灰烬，整个意义就丧失了。事实是，观看的人群欢呼雀跃，把他们的自由帽扔向空中，高喊罗伯斯庇尔万岁。罗伯斯庇尔又发表了一次演讲，我想还是没人能听见。然后每个人都加入了一首爱国赞美诗，这是专门为这个场合创作的。所以，我的意思是，乐趣是无限的。然后那天下午，还有另一场奇观。这发生在战神广场的中间，就在埃菲尔铁塔现在矗立的地方下方，
now stands and all the deputies in the crowds have processed there from the tuileries. And there, in the previous episode, Dominic, there was a Papiomache mountain that had been built in the nave of Notre Dame. This is on a vastly greater scale. It's been built by David, so presumably is excellent. David has tremendous taste. I mean, a skeptic might say the French Revolution is spending an awful lot of time making things that normally are made by four-year-olds in preschool glasses. Yeah, you might say that, but four-year-olds don't tend to put statues of Apollo on top of their papio-mache mountains, which is what David has done. Right. And also there's a tree on the summit, which I think is impressive.
所有的代表和人群都从杜伊勒里宫游行到那里。在那里，多米尼克，上一集里，巴黎圣母院的中殿里建了一座纸糊山。这次规模要大得多。它是大卫建造的，所以想必非常出色。大卫有极好的品味。我的意思是，怀疑论者可能会说法国大革命花了很多时间制作通常由学龄前儿童在幼儿园制作的东西。是的，你可能会这么说，但四岁的孩子通常不会在他们的纸糊山上放阿波罗雕像，而大卫就是这么做的。没错。而且山顶上还有一棵树，我觉得这很令人印象深刻。
I mean, I've never seen a papio-masho mountain with a tree on the summit. Town nursery in Chippee Norton does some pretty good stuff, to be fair. The fate. Yeah, flower show. Nice. Anyway, so this is the huge papi-a-mashy mountain, and it's the measure of the scale of it is that all the deputy climb up the side of it. And Robespierre purchased himself right on the summit.
我的意思是，我从来没见过山顶上有树的纸糊山。奇平诺顿的城镇幼儿园确实做了一些相当不错的东西，说实话。那个节日。是的，花展。不错。总之，这是一座巨大的纸糊山，衡量它规模的标准是所有的代表都爬上了它的侧面。
So the deputies then kind of congregate around him. And meanwhile, the mass choir that David's been rehearsing. So that's all 2,400 of them. They perched themselves decorously on the lower slopes of the mountain. So, I mean, that is a massive amount of Papua Mache. I mean, I think that's quite impressive. I would enjoy seeing that. And I might also enjoy the spectacle that then ensues,
所以代表们就聚集在他周围。与此同时，大卫一直在排练的大型合唱团，也就是那2400人，他们庄重地栖息在山的下坡上。所以，我的意思是，那可是大量的纸糊。我的意思是，我觉得这相当令人印象深刻。我会喜欢看那个。我也可能会喜欢随之而来的奇观，
because it's an assemblage of patriotic songs. Okay. Do you like a patriotic song? Depends where it's from. I mean, a patriotic song from our own beloved country or from, I don't know, Costa Rica or Bosnia, I'd be all in favour of that. A patroatic song from just across the channel, maybe not.
因为它是一场爱国歌曲的汇编。好的。你喜欢爱国歌曲吗？取决于它来自哪里。我的意思是，来自我们自己心爱的国家，或者来自，我不知道，哥斯达黎加或波斯尼亚的爱国歌曲，我都会支持。来自海峡对岸的爱国歌曲，可能不会。
I think the odds that they're singing patriotic English songs on a Papiomache mountain in the middle of the French Revolution are low. I mean, these are French ones. And then there's this specially composed. him and we'll be coming later to who this hymn is being sung to or what. Those are the kind of the festivities on the Papiamesh mountain and then finally in a way that is deliberately designed to ape the athletic contests of ancient Greece. There is a display of sports. The crowds drift away and
我认为他们在法国大革命期间在纸糊山上唱英国爱国歌曲的可能性很低。我的意思是，这些是法国的。然后还有这首特别创作的赞美诗，我们稍后会谈到这首赞美诗是唱给谁听的，或者是什么。这些就是纸糊山上的庆祝活动，然后最后，以一种刻意模仿古希腊体育竞赛的方式，有一场体育表演。人群散去，
it's generally agreed that a good time has been had by all. Wonderful. People enjoyed it. Although there are people who find this sinister. Are there not? Ludicrous and sinister, I would say. Okay. Because some of the deputies who followed Ros Pierre in a train, you know, like a kind of a crocodile, a school procession, they followed him from the tuileries down to this Papiomache Mountain, and then they followed him up the side of the Papiomache Mountain, and they've had to congregate all around him.
人们普遍认为大家都度过了一段美好的时光。太棒了。人们很享受。尽管有些人觉得这很阴险。不是吗？我会说既荒谬又阴险。好的。因为一些跟随罗伯斯庇尔的代表，你知道，就像一条鳄鱼，一个学校游行队伍，他们从杜伊勒里宫跟着他走到这座纸糊山，然后他们跟着他爬上纸糊山的侧面，他们不得不聚集在他周围。
And they are scoffing and sneering and bitching away like nobody's business, loads of them. They really think it's ludicrous. And I think that the general feeling is that the whole occasion is mad that this is a bizarre way to spend your time
他们在那儿冷嘲热讽，抱怨个不停，很多人都是这样。他们真的觉得这很荒谬。而且我认为普遍的感觉是整个场合是疯狂的，这是一种度过时间的怪异方式。
the people who particularly feel this are the atheists because the atheists have just seen this like this cardboard guy with the asses ears portraying their atheism torched and the whole occasion despite the tricklers
特别有这种感觉的人是无神论者，因为无神论者刚刚看到这个长着驴耳朵的纸板家伙描绘他们的无神论被烧毁，整个场合尽管有三色饰带，
despite the patriotic songs the object of the celebrations hasn't really overtly been the revolution it's been a god and this god isn't even a god with which most people are familiar, because it's a very chill, distant, anemic god. And this is a god termed by Rovspierre, L'Etre Suprem, the Supreme Being.
尽管有爱国歌曲，但庆祝活动的对象并不是革命，而是一个神，而且这个神甚至不是大多数人熟悉的神，因为这是一个非常冷漠、遥远、贫血的神。这就是罗伯斯庇尔所称的“最高主宰”（L'Etre Supreme）。
And this is what it's all about. This is a festival in honour of the supreme being. Now, who is the supreme being? So back in November, people may remember, Ross Pierre goes to the Jacoban Club and he publicly confronts the atheist trend that's been catching fire among the Montigny. And he opposed this by saying that even if God didn't exist, it would be necessary to invent him, kind of echoing the famous aphorism of Voltaire. But Robs-Pier definitely thinks that there is a God.
这就是这一切的意义所在。这是一个纪念最高主宰的节日。那么，谁是最高主宰？回到十一月，人们可能还记得，罗伯斯庇尔去了雅各宾俱乐部，他公开对抗在山岳派中蔓延的无神论趋势。他反对这一点，说即使上帝不存在，也有必要创造他，这有点呼应了伏尔泰的名言。但罗伯斯庇尔绝对认为有一个上帝。
And this is the God that he calls the supreme deity. And he denies that he has invented this God. He thinks this God exists. and he says that this is the god of the people and that to think otherwise, to doubt the existence of this God is counter-revolutionary. So in this speech that he gave in the Jacques-Abaugh,
这就是他所说的最高神。他否认他创造了这个上帝。他认为这个上帝存在，他说这是人民的上帝，认为不然，怀疑这个上帝的存在就是反革命。所以在他雅各宾俱乐部的演讲中，
he declared that atheism is aristocratic, which might sound ludicrous to us, but if you think about the tradition of aristocratic atheism in France, Marquis de Sard is the most notorious exemplar, but the kind of sense that the characters that you would find in dangerous liaisons that they don't believe in God at all
他宣称无神论是贵族式的，这在我们听来可能很荒谬，但如果你想想法国贵族无神论的传统，萨德侯爵是最臭名昭著的例子，但你在《危险关系》中会发现的那些角色根本不相信上帝的感觉，
is very, very strong. Surely, I mean, yeah, the common people that Robespierre claims to represent. They all love God. They're not atheists. No, they're all believers. And so this is why it has some force. And Robsfier then goes on to say,
是非常非常强烈的。当然，我的意思是，是的，罗伯斯庇尔声称代表的普通民众。他们都爱上帝。他们不是无神论者。不，他们都是信徒。所以这就是为什么它有一些力量。然后罗伯斯庇尔继续说，
the idea of a great being who watches over oppressed innocence and punishes triumphant crime is one that entirely belongs to the people. So in essence, he's saying that if people don't believe that there is justice in the afterlife, then how can they possibly believe that there is justice? justice in this life. That, I think, is essentially the core of his argument.
一个注视着受压迫的无辜者并惩罚胜利的罪恶的伟大存在的想法，是完全属于人民的。所以本质上，他是在说，如果人们不相信来世有正义，那么他们怎么可能相信今生有正义呢？我认为，这本质上是他论点的核心。
And that if they come to feel that there is no justice in this life, then they will relapse into cynicism and despair. And that is not what a revolution needs at all. Well, is it not right that basically for Rob Spier and so many of the other revolutionary radicals, their belief in the revolution is tied up with their belief in a kind of, in moral absolutes, in an absolute morality? And if you take that away, then you have nothing. And they, you know, Rob Spierre lives in a world, as we've talked about so many times in this series of virtue and terror.
如果他们开始觉得今生没有正义，那么他们就会陷入愤世嫉俗和绝望。而这根本不是革命所需要的。那么，对于罗伯斯庇尔和许多其他激进的革命者来说，他们对革命的信仰与他们对某种道德绝对、绝对道德的信仰联系在一起，难道不是正确的吗？如果你把那个拿走，那么你就一无所有了。而且他们，你知道，罗伯斯庇尔生活在一个我们在这个系列中谈论过很多次的美德与恐怖的世界里。
And his belief in virtue, you know, it can't come from, it's not, you know, he's not a moral relativist. It doesn't come from nowhere. He believes that it is linked to a kind of metaphysical reality. Yes, that's exactly what he's saying. And more than that, he could point out that this idea, this notion of a supreme being who keeps watch over the revolution and is guiding it to its conclusion, that this has actually been catalyptuant. terminus with the revolution itself, because right from the beginning, the revolutionaries had been very keen to demonstrate and make exactly the point you were making that their ideals are not culturally relative, they're not contingent, they're not ideals that have been thrown up
他对美德的信仰，你知道，它不能来自，它不是，你知道，他不是一个道德相对主义者。它不是凭空而来的。他相信它与某种形而上学的现实联系在一起。是的，这正是他所说的。不仅如此，他还可以指出，这个想法，这个注视着革命并引导它走向终结的最高主宰的概念，实际上与革命本身是同时出现的，因为从一开始，革命者就非常热衷于证明并指出你刚才所说的观点，即他们的理想不是文化相对的，它们不是偶然的，它们不是由环境抛出的理想，
by circumstance, that they are absolute, they are eternal, they are universal, that is why the revolution can proclaim itself to be not just for the French, but for everyone, across the face of the planet. And in this, of course, the revolutionaries are very self-consciously following the example of the founding fathers in America. And it's telling that Thomas Jefferson, who was serving in Paris as the American ambassador in the summer of 1789, had actually been on hand to give them advice. No wonder it went to the dogs and they all ended up being terrible people. I mean, they were taking advice from one of the worst men in history. The role that Jefferson plays that's very significant, and we talked about this,
它们是绝对的，它们是永恒的，它们是普遍的，这就是为什么革命可以宣称自己不仅是为了法国人，而是为了地球上的每一个人。当然，在这方面，革命者非常自觉地遵循了美国开国元勋的榜样。值得注意的是，1789年夏天在巴黎担任美国大使的托马斯·杰斐逊实际上就在现场为他们提供建议。难怪它最后变得一团糟，他们都成了可怕的人。我的意思是，他们是在接受历史上最糟糕的人之一的建议。杰斐逊扮演的角色非常重要，我们谈论过这个，
this way back in our first series. He had helped the revolutionaries to draw up a kind of an equivalent of the Declaration of Independence with its insistence on human rights, the significance of human rights. And on the 26th of August 1789, the revolutionaries had not just formally asserted that human rights do exist, that they have a kind of absolute existence, but in very Jeffersonian terms had declared them to be natural, inalienable and sacred. Which, they called the Declaration of the Rights of Man and the Citizen, and it is still being honored in 74 as the foundational text of the entire revolution, and Robespierre absolutely reveres it. So back in 1793, he had said flatly, the Declaration of Rights is the Constitution of
早在我们的第一个系列中。他曾帮助革命者起草了一份类似于《独立宣言》的文件，强调人权，人权的重要性。1789年8月26日，革命者不仅正式断言人权确实存在，它们具有某种绝对的存在，而且以非常杰斐逊式的术语宣布它们是自然的、不可剥夺的和神圣的。他们称之为《人权和公民权宣言》，在74年它仍然被尊为整个革命的奠基文本，罗伯斯庇尔绝对崇敬它。所以早在1793年，他就断言：权利宣言是
all peoples, so not just the French, all peoples, it has a universal application, all other laws being variable by nature and subordinated to this one. And what enables him to feel confident in making this seemingly ludicrous assertion is another claim that had been made in the Declaration of Rights. It was there in black and white that the Declaration of Rights had been promulgated, and I quote, under the auspices of the supreme being. And it's this supreme being, Robs-Pier believes, who has engraved the laws of eternal justice, and again to quote the Declaration of Rights, not upon marble or stone, but in the hearts of all men. And this is, is a massive deal for Robespierre that this should be so, because for him, so much is at stake.
所有民族的宪法，不仅仅是法国人，是所有民族，它具有普遍的适用性，所有其他法律在本质上都是可变的，并从属于这一条。使他有信心做出这一看似荒谬的断言的是《权利宣言》中提出的另一个主张。黑纸白字地写着《权利宣言》是在，我引用，“最高主宰的庇护下”颁布的。罗伯斯庇尔相信，正是这位最高主宰，将永恒正义的法则，再次引用《权利宣言》，不是刻在大理石或石头上，而是刻在所有人的心中。这对罗伯斯庇尔来说是一件大事，因为对他来说，利害攸关。
Because should the French doubt that the promptings of what they can read on their hearts is genuinely expressive of the purposes of a divine being, then he fears the worst. And what he fears is the return of the tyranny that the revolution has been launched to overthrow, so basically the tyranny of kings. Because citizens to behave well, Rochpier believes, need to feel that they are being watched at all times, because only then will they be steel to follow the course of virtue. If they don't feel they're being watched, then they might get up to all kinds of shenanigans. And only if they follow the course of virtue, will the revolution be fully secured. And there's a brilliant book on this by a guy called Dan Edelstein, The Terror of Natural Right,
因为如果法国人怀疑他们心中所读到的东西是否真正表达了神圣存在的意图，那么他担心最坏的情况。他所担心的是革命旨在推翻的暴政的回归，也就是国王的暴政。因为罗伯斯庇尔认为，公民要表现良好，需要感到他们时刻受到监视，因为只有这样，他们才会被激励去遵循美德的道路。如果他们不觉得有人在监视他们，那么他们可能会搞出各种各样的恶作剧。只有遵循美德的道路，革命才能得到充分的保障。关于这一点，丹·埃德尔斯坦有一本出色的书，《自然权利的恐怖》，
This is why at the festival, the supreme being is symbolized, to quote Edelstein, primarily as a disembodied eye. So an eye that can see into the heart of every citizen, and Edelstein describes it as an internalized surveillance mechanism. Is that not a very common 18th century device, the idea of the supreme being is an eye and one that owes something to freemasonry, and you see it in the American iconography as well, the dollar bill? So it is current among kind of free-thinking intellectuals, this idea of a saron-type, lidless eye, gazing and penetrating and watching.
这就是为什么在节日上，最高主宰被象征为，引用埃德尔斯坦的话，主要是一个无形的眼睛。所以是一只可以看到每个公民内心的眼睛，埃德尔斯坦将其描述为一种内在化的监视机制。这难道不是一种非常常见的18世纪装置吗？最高主宰是一个眼睛的想法，而且它归功于共济会，你在美国的肖像中也能看到它，比如美元钞票？所以这种想法在自由思想的知识分子中很流行，这种萨伦式的、无眼睑的眼睛，凝视、穿透并注视着。
And this is why Rosfeyer stages the festival of the Supreme Being, and it's why its success matters so much to him, because he essentially believes that in its success lies the best prospects for the future of the entire revolution. He believes as passionately there are all kinds of people who obviously think this is mad. But the reason that Robespierre is so insistent on staging this festival is that he believes that if the people come to doubt the existence of a benignant but all seeing God, then their prospects of arriving at true virtue are completely shot. You know, that they will start behaving like aristocrats like libertines. They will get up to all kinds of terrible things. Rob Spier psychologically, and this is, I think, reflected in the way he dresses and the way he carries himself, he's a man who believes in rules. and order. Is he not? He's a man to whom controlled is incredibly important. And so the idea that you could have a kind of moral free-for-all, where people, you know, pursue their own individual
这就是罗伯斯庇尔举办最高主宰节的原因，也是它成功与否对他如此重要的原因，因为他本质上相信，它的成功在于整个革命未来的最佳前景。他充满激情地相信，尽管显然有各种各样的人认为这很疯狂。但罗伯斯庇尔如此坚持举办这个节日的原因是，他相信如果人们开始怀疑一个仁慈但全知全能的上帝的存在，那么他们获得真正美德的前景就完全破灭了。你知道，他们会开始像贵族、像浪子一样行事。他们会做出各种可怕的事情。罗伯斯庇尔在心理上，我认为这反映在他穿衣和举止的方式上，是一个相信规则和秩序的人。
morality, the idea that you would take off the shackles, as it were, which is presumably what people like Ebert and the atheists wanted to do. Let's have a kind of anarchic world order. That, you can get the sense with him, I think, that that fills him with a kind of deep psychological horror. He lives in a world where, you know, you're still wearing your wig, you're still wearing his stockings, you're sticking to rigid formulae, and he wants to find a formula to sort of anchor the revolution to something, don't you think? Yeah. Well, remember when he was a little boy, the comment that his sister made about him, that he didn't often play games, but when he did, it was always to insist on the rules. Yes, exactly. And I think that is Rosbya's light
不是吗？他是一个认为控制极其重要的人。所以，那种你可以拥有某种道德自由放任的想法，人们，你知道，追求他们自己个人的
motif throughout his entire career. And there's a sense in which he hasn't given up on the rule. So even though the terror is gouts of blood spurting from the guillotine every day, it's not his ambition to preside over terror. That's not why he's come into politics to do. He doesn't want to rule as a dictator. What he's really about is his constitution, which he hopes when it has been brought in will enable France to live, you know, and be a happy, emancipated, terror-free country. We've talked about it several times this constitution that Rospierre and Saint-Jouz and Couton between them had drawn up very, very quickly in the early summer of 1793. And they had invested all their hopes in it. And it had been by leaps and bounds the most democratic
道德，那种你会解开枷锁的想法，这大概就是像埃贝尔和无神论者想要做的事情。让我们拥有某种无政府的世界秩序。你可以感觉到，我认为，这让他充满了某种深刻的心理恐惧。他生活在一个，你知道，你仍然戴着假发，仍然穿着长袜，坚持僵化公式的世界里，他想找到一个公式来锚定革命，你不觉得吗？是的。嗯，记得他小时候他姐姐对他的评价吗？他不常玩游戏，但当他玩的时候，总是坚持规则。是的，正是如此。我认为那是罗伯斯庇尔整个职业生涯的基调。
constitution that the modern world had ever seen. And then it had been ratified by this popular referendum, by an overwhelming majority. And to Robespier, this had served to make it into something holy. It was something that the people whom he identifies as being the voice of virtue, they had said, yes, we want this. So this constitution is incredibly precious to him. I would go so far as to say holy to him. And this is why, I mean, it's such an extraordinary detail. Once it's been ratified, it gets ceremonially placed in a model of the Ark of the Covenant that David has kind of rustled up especially for it. And so the iconography of this is very obvious, I think, and deliberate, that what the God of the Bible had been to the Israelites, so God gives the tablets of stone
在某种意义上，他并没有放弃规则。所以即使恐怖统治每天都有鲜血从断头台喷涌而出，他的野心也不是主持恐怖。那不是他进入政治的原因。他不想作为独裁者统治。他真正关心的是他的宪法，他希望当它被引入时，能使法国能够生活，你知道，成为一个快乐、解放、没有恐怖的国家。我们已经多次谈到这部宪法，罗伯斯庇尔、圣茹斯特和库通在1793年初夏非常非常迅速地起草了它。他们把所有的希望都寄托在它身上。它一直是现代世界所见过的最民主的
the law to Moses, and these tablets are then placed in the Ark of the Covenant. The supreme being is to the Jacobin, is to the Montigny, is to the revolution as a whole. The constitution is something that is descended from the supreme being and therefore is literally dare one say sacral. And yet the irony, this is a constitution that because the nation is facing a national emergency of war, you know, rebellion in the Vande, the Federalist revolts in the cities and so on, this constitution has never been introduced. And at this point in time, which is, what is it, June 1794, there are no signs that it ever
宪法。然后它通过了全民公投，以压倒性多数获得批准。对罗伯斯庇尔来说，这使它成为神圣的东西。这是人民，他将其视为美德之声的人，他们说，是的，我们想要这个。所以这部宪法对他来说极其珍贵。我甚至会说对他来说是神圣的。这就是为什么，我的意思是，这是一个如此非凡的细节。一旦它被批准，它就被仪式性地放置在大卫专门为它制作的约柜模型中。所以我想，这其中的肖像学是非常明显和刻意的，圣经中的上帝对以色列人来说是什么，上帝把石板
will be introduced because of the state of emergency. So this state of emergency is now, what are we, seven, eight months old and absolutely no sign that they even have a timetable for when they will scrap the state of emergency and move towards a democratic system. Absolutely. So there is no question. The constitution is in a state of animated suspension. In fact, it's in a state of literal suspension because on the suggestion of David, the constitution still in the arc of the covenant had been hung above the Speaker's Bar in the National Convention. So whenever anyone goes up to talk, there is the Ark of the Covenant with this Constitution kind of hanging above
法律赐给摩西，这些石板随后被放置在约柜中。最高主宰对雅各宾派，对山岳派，对整个革命来说也是如此。宪法是某种从最高主宰那里降临的东西，因此字面上，敢说的话，是神圣的。然而讽刺的是，这是一部因为国家面临战争的国家紧急状态，你知道，旺代叛乱，城市里的联邦主义者起义等等，而从未被引入的宪法。在此时此刻，也就是，这是什么，1794年6月，没有任何迹象表明它
them. I think that you may disagree with this, but I think that Robespierre is intensely frustrated by this. He wants to see this constitution brought in. So Arar Palmer, who we've been quoting quite a lot, is brilliant. on the Committee of Public Safety. I mean, he says that Robespierre regarded dictatorship as an interim phase necessary rather than desirable is beyond a possibility of question. I mean, I don't know. Do you agree with that?
会被引入，因为紧急状态。所以这种紧急状态现在，我们是，七、八个月大了，绝对没有任何迹象表明他们甚至有一个时间表来决定何时取消紧急状态并转向民主制度。绝对没有。所以毫无疑问。宪法处于一种动画般的暂停状态。事实上，它处于一种字面上的暂停状态，因为在大卫的建议下，宪法仍然在约柜里，被悬挂在国民公会的议长席上方。所以每当有人上去发言时，就有约柜和这部宪法悬挂在
I think it's complicated. I mean, we could spend hours talking about this. I think absolutely if you asked Robespierre or if you asked himself, he would say that, yes, of course, the dictatorship is an unfortunate short-term necessity and that eventually we will embrace this constitution and I will step back or whatever. However, I think practically there is no moment. I don't think that moment would ever have arrived for Robespierre. I don't think there was ever a point where he would have said,
他们上方。我想你可能不同意这一点，但我认为罗伯斯庇尔对这一点感到非常沮丧。他希望看到这部宪法被引入。所以阿拉·帕尔默，我们引用了很多次，他在公共安全委员会方面非常出色。我的意思是，他说罗伯斯庇尔认为独裁是一种必要的过渡阶段，而不是理想的，这是毫无疑问的。我的意思是，我不知道。你同意吗？
now we can stop the terror. Corruption has been eradicated. The threats are gone. I think he has got himself into a mental psychological state where France will never be ready for that constitution. And you can argue that's a kind of tragedy for him, arguably an even greater tragedy for the people who are rattling a lot of, Yeah, the streets and the tumbrils to the guillotine.
我认为这很复杂。我的意思是，我们可以花几个小时谈论这个。我认为绝对的，如果你问罗伯斯庇尔，或者如果你问他自己，他会说，是的，当然，独裁是一种不幸的短期必要，最终我们将拥抱这部宪法，我会退后一步等等。然而，我认为实际上没有那个时刻。我不认为那个时刻对罗伯斯庇尔来说会到来。我不认为有任何一点他会说，
I mean, I think he definitely wants to see his constitution introduced. I also agree with you that he is finding it increasingly hard to imagine a situation in which that would be possible. And the reason for that is he is finding it very difficult to identify who the truly virtuous are. Because he's coming round to a perspective that those who see most virtuous may be most counter-revolutionary. And I think the consciousness of this is causing him immense mental anguish.
现在我们可以停止恐怖了。腐败已经被根除。威胁已经消失。我认为他已经进入了一种心理状态，法国永远不会为那部宪法做好准备。你可以说这对他是某种悲剧，可以说对那些在街上和去断头台的囚车上的人来说是一个更大的悲剧。
Yeah, I agree. I think he's in a mental state now where he thinks there are people who are obviously counter-revolutionary, corrupt and so on, are traitors. But he's now got to the point, I think, where he's got himself into such a lather that he thinks, actually, do you know what, the more that people appear to be on my side, virtuous, upstanding, devoted to the revolution, they're really, likely to be traitors as well, and that basically you can't win with him. Yeah. And so this is why, although he remains personally opposed to the death penalty, he feels himself obliged to kill so many people, because all along he thought the future of the revolution depends on this. And even though he's personally squeamish, he's ideologically opposed to guillotining, he feels that it is his moral responsibility as the man charged with
我的意思是，我认为他绝对希望看到他的宪法被引入。我也同意你的观点，他越来越难以想象这种情况会成为可能。原因是他发现很难确定谁是真正有美德的人。因为他开始有一种观点，即那些看起来最有美德的人可能是最反革命的。我认为这种意识正在给他带来巨大的精神痛苦。
the guidance of the revolution. to do it. And in his, he delivers this famous speech on how terror is virtuous. He spelt this out very clearly. If the basis of popular government in time of peace is virtue, that's what the constitution represents. The basis of popular government in time of revolution is both virtue and terror because virtue without terror is murderous and terror without virtue is powerless. And this is the bind that he's in. It's the corner he's backed himself into. It's a tragedy for him. Obviously, it's a tragedy for everyone who is having their heads chopped off. He is a very psychologically familiar case of a deeply controlled, anxious, you know, rule-bound person who cannot understand why other people don't play by the same rules.
是的，我同意。我认为他现在处于一种心理状态，他认为有些人显然是反革命的、腐败的等等，是叛徒。但我认为他现在已经到了那种地步，他把自己逼到了那种境地，他认为，实际上，你知道吗，那些看起来越站在我这边的人，有美德、正直、致力于革命的人，他们实际上也很可能是叛徒，基本上你无法赢得他的信任。是的。所以这就是为什么，尽管他个人仍然反对死刑，但他觉得有义务杀死这么多人，因为他一直认为革命的未来取决于此。尽管他个人很挑剔，他在意识形态上反对断头台，但他觉得作为负责
Why do people keep behaving badly? Why do they keep taking bribes? Why aren't they pure? why do they let themselves down and all these ways? He's getting more and more frustrated and psychologically he will just never get it. He doesn't, he would not meet the humid race halfway, basically.
引导革命的人，这是他的道德责任。去做吧。在他著名的关于恐怖为何是美德的演讲中，他非常清楚地阐明了这一点。如果和平时期大众政府的基础是美德，这就是宪法所代表的。革命时期大众政府的基础既是美德又是恐怖，因为没有恐怖的美德是杀人的，没有美德的恐怖是无力的。这就是他所处的困境。这是他把自己逼入的角落。对他来说这是一个悲剧。显然，这对每一个被砍头的人来说都是一个悲剧。他是一个非常心理上熟悉的案例，一个深受控制、焦虑、你知道，受规则约束的人，他不明白为什么其他人不按同样的规则行事。
No. And so I think in turn that cements him in his opinion that he really is the protector of the revolution because there isn't anyone else, perhaps Sanjouz. But the future of the revolution depends on him because he's basically the only one who's following the rules. And so everyone has to be brought to follow the rules. and if they don't then off with their heads.
为什么人们总是表现得很糟糕？为什么他们总是收受贿赂？为什么他们不纯洁？为什么他们以所有这些方式让自己失望？他越来越沮丧，在心理上他永远不会明白。他，他基本上不会与人类达成妥协。
Now, this is why the festival of the Supreme Being matters so much to him because it seems to offer him a way out because suppose in place of the Committee of Public Safety are sentinel over the French people. You have a restless and all-seeing eye, the eye of the supreme being. This from Rob Spears' point of view
不。所以我认为反过来，这巩固了他的观点，即他确实是革命的保护者，因为没有其他人，也许圣茹斯特除外。但革命的未来取决于他，因为他基本上是唯一一个遵守规则的人。所以每个人都必须被带去遵守规则，如果他们不这样做，那就砍掉他们的头。
would be a brilliant solution. because if he can leave the enforcement of terror to the Supreme Being, then he won't need to be responsible for it himself. And that's why he stages the festival of the Supreme Being. It's why he's so delighted by its success. He thinks that maybe there is a sign here that the French people can be brought to respect the rules because now they are learning, you know, as in 1984, people are brought to love Big Brother,
现在，这就是为什么最高主宰节对他如此重要，因为它似乎为他提供了一条出路，因为假设在公共安全委员会的位置上，法国人民的哨兵。你有一个不安分且全知全能的眼睛，最高主宰的眼睛。从罗伯斯庇尔的角度来看，这会是一个绝妙的解决方案。因为如果他能把恐怖的执行留给最高主宰，那么他自己就不需要为此负责了。这就是他举办最高主宰节的原因。这就是他为何对它的成功感到如此高兴。他认为也许这里有一个迹象，表明法国人民可以被引导去尊重规则，因为现在他们正在学习，你知道，就像在《1984》中，人们被引导去爱老大哥，
people are being brought to love the Supreme Being. and pretty much every historian I've read who's written about Robespierre, they seem to concur that this festival was the single happiest day of his life because I think for the first time since the terror had begun, he can contemplate the lifting of this great burden that's on his shoulders. Wow. So has Robespierre in the Festival of the Supreme Being found his way out, has he found a way to direct the kind of moral and political life of the nation at last. Or by staging this Papier-Mashe festival, has he actually let himself
人们正被引导去热爱至高无上的存在。我读过的几乎每一位撰写罗伯斯庇尔的史学家似乎都一致认为，这次节日是他一生中最快乐的一天，因为我认为，自恐怖统治开始以来，他第一次能够考虑卸下肩上这副沉重的担子。哇。那么，罗伯斯庇尔在“至高存在节”中找到了出路吗？他终于找到了一种引导国家道德和政治生活的方式了吗？还是说，通过策划这场纸糊的节日，他实际上让自己
in for a whole load of trouble? And is he actually hastening towards his own demise? We will find out after the break. This episode is supported by Anthropic, the team behind Claude. Now, history's biggest leaps, many of them started as hard questions that people didn't want asked. Yeah, there's a classic example of that, Tom, at the end of the 15th century. And the hard question in particular was, what is out there beyond the Atlantic Ocean to the west? And as you will know, the man who found the answer to that question was the explorer Christopher Columbus, great pioneering voyage of discovery, and it is, of course, the Americas.
陷入了巨大的麻烦之中？他是否正在加速走向自己的灭亡？休息之后，我们将揭晓答案。本集由Anthropic赞助，这是Claude背后的团队。现在，历史上最大的飞跃，其中许多始于人们不想被问及的难题。是的，汤姆，15世纪末有一个经典的例子。那个难题特别在于，大西洋以西的海洋之外有什么？正如你所知，找到那个问题答案的人是探险家克里斯托弗·哥伦布，伟大的发现之旅，当然，那就是美洲。
So, you know, Anthropic knows the importance of questions, and it's why Anthropic is founded on one hard question above all. How can we ensure that the AI revolution really goes well for ordinary people. Anthropic asked 100,000 people, and what came back wasn't just fear. There was hope as well. People wanted to know, will cancer ever be cured?
所以，你知道，Anthropic了解问题的重要性，这就是为什么Anthropic的创立基于一个最重要的难题。我们如何确保人工智能革命真正为普通人带来福祉？Anthropic询问了10万人，得到的反馈不仅仅是恐惧。还有希望。人们想知道，癌症会被治愈吗？
Can kids have a better future? It turns out that there is hope in hard questions. Ask yours at clod.a.I. and rest is history. And keep thinking. Strategic struggle between Britain and Russia. We assess Prime Minister. With high confidence it was Russian.
孩子们能有更好的未来吗？事实证明，难题中蕴含着希望。在clod.a.I.上提出你的问题，剩下的就是历史了。继续思考。英国与俄罗斯之间的战略斗争。我们评估首相。我们有高度信心是俄罗斯人所为。
Holding the Russians accountable is World War III. They took down a British passenger jet containing 350 people. Man in the Kremlin is playing, Alex. Got to ask yourself, you want to play or not? You're the Prime Minister. You've done nothing! We would need to understand the policy context. All the relevant context.
追究俄罗斯人的责任就是第三次世界大战。他们击落了一架载有350人的英国客机。克里姆林宫的那个人在玩弄权术，亚历克斯。你得问问自己，你想玩还是不想玩？你是首相。你什么都没做！我们需要了解政策背景。所有相关的背景。
will be structured as a framework today and disseminated into an operation order, or Fraggo. A Fraggo that says to kill the president of Russia. Yes. New from Goldhanger. Who is going to be able to pull this off? You're my soldier, are you? Sergeant Tom McDuff, Duffy.
今天将构建为一个框架，并分发到作战命令或Fraggo中。一个要求杀死俄罗斯总统的Fraggo。是的。Goldhanger出品的新作。谁能完成这个任务？你是我的士兵，对吧？汤姆·麦克达夫中士，达菲。
An audio drama journey like no other. Men like Duffy, they are our most valuable weapons. Devised as a technical... rigorous geopolitical action thriller. We have two times friendly key. Where Britain plays its strongest hand. He's the best. Against its strongest foe. Bear Hunt.
一场独一无二的音频剧之旅。像达菲这样的人，是我们最宝贵的武器。构思为一部技术性……严谨的地缘政治动作惊悚片。我们有两次友军识别。英国发挥了最强手牌。他是最棒的。对抗它最强大的敌人。猎熊。
Available now, wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome back to the rest is history. Look at the bastard. It's not enough for him to be master. He must be God. So this was a bloke, a deputy, in the National Convention called Jacques Alexis Tuchio. and Turio was sitting, I mean, he was effectively sitting at the feet of Rob Speer
现已上线，可在任何收听播客的地方获取。欢迎回到《剩下的就是历史》。看看那个混蛋。仅仅做主人对他来说是不够的。他必须是上帝。所以这是一个家伙，国民公会的一名代表，名叫雅克·亚历克西斯·图里奥。图里奥当时坐在，我的意思是，他实际上是坐在罗伯斯庇尔的脚下
on this massive Papier-Mache Mountain, the stuff of a nursery school's wildest imaginings. It's like a kind of illustration from a children's Bible, isn't it? Of the disciples gathered around the feet of Jesus during the sermon of the Mount or something like that. Yeah, exactly. If you ever see pictures of the Tower of Babel, they always look like it's been made out of Papier-Machet. This is a sort of more natural world version of. of that. Anyway, Turio is sitting at the bottom of this flipping mountain that's been made by Jacques Louis David for the festival of the Supreme Being. And Turio is not enamored of the entire occasion.
在那座巨大的纸糊山上，那是幼儿园最狂野的想象。这就像儿童圣经中的一种插图，不是吗？就像耶稣在山上布道时聚集在脚下的门徒，或者类似的东西。是的，完全正确。如果你见过巴别塔的图片，它们看起来总是像纸糊的一样。这是那种场景的某种更自然世界的版本。总之，图里奥正坐在雅克·路易·大卫为至高存在节制作的这座该死的山脚下。图里奥对整个场合并不着迷。
In fact, he regards it as completely laughable, doesn't he? In fact, worse than laughable. He regards it as laughable and sinister. Yes, he does. And I think all the more so, because actually he knows Robespierre well, because the previous summer they'd both been on the Committee of Public Safety together. But Turio was an admirer. of Dantan, the kind of, you know, he thinks that Robespierre has taken a wrong course. And so he had resigned in September from the committee protesting against the kind of the surge of executions declaring, we must halt this raging torrent which is leading us to barbarism. So that was Turio in September 1793. Intriguingly, however, in general, his
事实上，他认为这完全是可笑的，不是吗？事实上，比可笑更糟。他认为这既可笑又阴险。是的，他确实这么认为。而且我认为更是如此，因为实际上他很了解罗伯斯庇尔，因为去年夏天他们都在救国委员会共事过。但图里奥是丹东的崇拜者，那种，你知道，他认为罗伯斯庇尔走错了路。因此，他在1793年9月辞去了委员会的职务，抗议那种处决浪潮，宣称：“我们必须阻止这股导致我们走向野蛮的狂暴洪流。”这就是1793年9月的图里奥。然而，有趣的是，总的来说，他的
disapproval of Robespier is not because he sees Robespierre as an extremist. but the opposite. He sees Robs-Pierre and criticises him as such, as a moderate. And by calling Rovst-Pierre God, Turyo is actually awarding him a promotion because most of Robespier's critics, when they insult him along these terms, tend to refer to the incorruptible as a priest. And it's the quality of the priestly in Robespierre that revolts and disgusts, Turio. He sees Robespierre as reactionary in that sense, that he is upholding superstitious standards
对罗伯斯庇尔的不满并不是因为他认为罗伯斯庇尔是一个极端分子。恰恰相反。他看待罗伯斯庇尔并以此批评他，认为他是一个温和派。通过称罗伯斯庇尔为上帝，图里奥实际上是在给他升职，因为大多数罗伯斯庇尔的批评者在用这些词汇侮辱他时，往往称这位“不可腐蚀者”为牧师。正是罗伯斯庇尔身上那种牧师般的特质让图里奥感到反感和厌恶。他认为罗伯斯庇尔在那种意义上是反动的，因为他坚持迷信的标准，
that he feels an enlightened and revolutionary people should be getting rid of. There's always a tendency, isn't there, among, there's a long-running antipathy that you find where more worldly people often resent, dislike and slightly look down on people who are very earnest, very heartfelt, a little bit prissy. You know, the little boy who says to his fellows, why won't you play by the rules? The rules say we should do this. The other boys don't always look on that boy with tremendous approval, do they?
他觉得一个开明和革命的人民应该摆脱这些。有一种倾向，不是吗？在长期的反感中，你会发现那些更世俗的人往往会怨恨、不喜欢并稍微看不起那些非常认真、非常真诚、有点拘谨的人。你知道，那个对同伴说“你们为什么不按规则玩？规则说我们应该这样做”的小男孩。其他男孩并不总是以极大的赞许来看待那个男孩，对吧？
And there's something of that, I think, with Tuchio and some of the others, and Robespierre. They just don't understand why he's such a drip and a fun sponge. I don't think they think he's a drip, but I do think they think he's a fun sponge, definitely. And I think they feel that he's a fun sponge in the way the priests have always been fun sponges. Yeah.
我认为图里奥和其他一些人对罗伯斯庇尔也有类似的感觉。他们只是不明白为什么他这么无趣，这么扫兴。我不认为他们认为他是个无趣的人，但我确实认为他们认为他绝对是个扫兴的人。而且我认为他们觉得他扫兴的方式就像牧师一直以来都是扫兴的人一样。是的。
Robespierre is obviously passionately interested in questions of morality and religion. You know, you were saying how he's not bothering himself with the practical demands of logistics or food provision for the army or anything like that. He's all about questions of virtue. Let me assure the listeners, there is nothing worse than somebody who is always talking to you about religion, just to be clear. And yet here we are talking about religion, Dominic. Yeah, I know. I'm too real in this analogy, by the way. And then there's the fact that Robespier does inspire this kind of fanatical devotion,
罗伯斯庇尔显然对道德和宗教问题充满热情。你知道，你刚才说他并不关心后勤或军队粮食供应等实际需求。他关心的全是美德问题。让我向听众保证，没有什么比总是跟你谈论宗教的人更糟糕的了，明确一下。然而，我们现在正在谈论宗教，多米尼克。是的，我知道。顺便说一句，我在这个类比中太真实了。还有，罗伯斯庇尔确实激发了这种狂热的奉献，
and particularly from women, and it is often said by his critics, his male critics, that this is typical of a priest, that women are far more inc, are naturally superstitious and therefore prone to the blandishness of a priest-like figure. So that's a criticism. And then, of course, in the autumn of 1793, there had come this overt declaration of war against atheism. So, I mean, it's very clear. he stood up in the Jacobin who were accustomed to kind of radical declarations of let's rip everything up and bring in a new world and he had said,
特别是来自女性的奉献，他的男性批评者经常说，这是牧师的典型特征，女性天生更迷信，因此容易受到牧师式人物的诱惑。所以这是一个批评。当然，在1793年秋天，出现了对无神论的公开宣战。所以，我的意思是，这很清楚。他在雅各宾派中站起来，他们习惯了那种激进的宣言，比如“让我们撕毁一切，建立一个新世界”，而他说，
whoever tries to stop the saying of mass is a worse fanatic than the priest who says it. And I think there were a lot of jaws dropping when Rolfs-Pierre made that statement. And to someone like Turio, who wasn't just an atheist, but a very committed de-Christianizer, he saw this as fundamental to the cause
“任何试图阻止弥撒的人，都比做弥撒的牧师更狂热。”我想当罗伯斯庇尔发表那番言论时，很多人都惊掉了下巴。对于像图里奥这样的人来说，他不仅是一个无神论者，而且是一个非常坚定的去基督教化者，他认为这对于革命应该采取的事业来说是根本性的。
that the revolution should be taking. It had come as a massive shock to hear the supposed leader of the Montagnan say such a thing. And so he comes to see Robsbyr not just as moderate, but verging on the counter-revolutionary. Yeah, because that anti-clericalism is such an important part of the revolution, isn't it? There are so many of those middle-class Montanier deputies who are fired up with a loathing of Catholic priests and are determined to basically rip out all the churches and all of that sort of thing. And I think it's as much, there's a sort of political, psychological, aesthetic quality to it as much as anything. They can't get why Rob Spierre is not on board with that.
听到山岳派的所谓领袖说出这样的话，这让他感到巨大的震惊。因此，他开始不仅把罗伯斯庇尔视为温和派，而且认为他近乎反革命。是的，因为那种反教权主义是革命中如此重要的一部分，不是吗？有那么多中产阶级的山岳派代表，他们对天主教神职人员充满了厌恶，并决心基本上铲除所有的教堂等等。我认为这在很大程度上有一种政治、心理和美学上的特质。他们不明白为什么罗伯斯庇尔不支持这一点。
And of course, Robespierre is right in the sense that most ordinary French men and women are baffled by all this because they're quite happy to, I mean, they might have resented the bishop or they might have resented the local priest, perfect. You know, they've structured their lives around the Christian calendar. They don't want to see it scrapped. Completely. Yeah. And so that is definitely a crucial part of why Rospier is opposed to de-Christianisation. He thinks that it's, you know, it's poking at a wasps nest. Why would you do this? You know, just let the wasps buzzer around if they're not causing any harm. But I think also to do Rospier credit, it's, you know, he's not just being cynical about it. It's a point of principle for him that there should be freedom of religion. So, kind of Elizabeth the first style, he said there is no commanding of consciences. He genuinely believes that.
当然，罗伯斯庇尔是对的，因为大多数普通的法国男女都被这一切搞糊涂了，因为他们很高兴，我的意思是，他们可能怨恨主教或当地的牧师，没关系。你知道，他们围绕基督教历法构建了自己的生活。他们不想看到它被废除。完全是这样。是的。所以这绝对是罗伯斯庇尔反对去基督教化的一个关键原因。他认为这就像是在捅马蜂窝。你为什么要这样做？你知道，如果马蜂不造成伤害，就让它们嗡嗡叫吧。但我认为，给罗伯斯庇尔一点赞誉，你知道，他不仅仅是在玩世不恭。对他来说，宗教自由是一个原则问题。所以，有点像伊丽莎白一世的风格，他说“没有对良心的指挥”。他是真心相信这一点的。
Now, acknowledging that much, this principle for Rods-Pier does come with a serious caveat, namely that Christianity must know its place, or indeed any religion, Judaism or whatever, Protestantism. He does think it is insupportable for priests to start barging into areas that they have no right to poke their noses into. So while Robs Pierre is fine with the Christianity that confines itself purely to the private sphere, he is not happy at all with a Christianity that, for instance, backs kings or priests who have not sworn oaths to support the revolution, that actually maybe identifies itself overtly with counter-revolution. And there's an obvious reason for this, because there's been this massive war going in in the Vonday and in the
现在，承认这一点，罗伯斯庇尔的这个原则确实带有一个严重的警告，即基督教必须知道它的位置，或者任何宗教，犹太教或其他，新教。他确实认为牧师开始闯入他们无权插手的领域是不可容忍的。所以，虽然罗伯斯庇尔对局限于私人领域的基督教没意见，但他对那种支持国王或未宣誓支持革命的牧师的基督教一点也不高兴，那种可能公开认同反革命的基督教。这有一个明显的原因，因为在旺代和法国的西部地区一直在进行大规模的战争，那里的叛军一直在有意识地试图阻止革命。他们一直在衣服上佩戴圣心。他们在军事行动前一直在参加弥撒。他们一直在高喊上帝和国王作为他们的战斗口号。罗伯斯庇尔绝不可能容忍这一点。因此，他完全认识到有必要教育广大人民摆脱这种迷信，如果有必要，甚至要残酷地进行。至于那些反对革命并向信徒宣扬上帝憎恨罗伯斯庇尔所作所为的牧师，他们显然是不可救药的。作为反革命分子，显然他们必须去断头台。果然，在恐怖统治期间，一千名这样的牧师确实去了断头台。所以罗伯斯庇尔对他们的处理方式一点也不温和。罗伯斯庇尔身上有一种非常新教的东西，不是吗？非常新教。我的意思是，正如我们将看到的，整个去基督教化浪潮中有一种非常新教的东西。你知道，关于教会与国家的关系，摆脱野蛮、落后的迷信，所有这些东西。
Western reaches of France, where rebels have been consciously attempting to stop the revolution. They've been wearing the sacred heart on their clothes. They've been attending mass before military engagements. They've been shouting out for God and the king as their war cry. There's no way that Robspierre is going to tolerate this. And so he completely recognizes that there is a need to educate the mass of the people out of superstitions such as this, and if necessary, brutally so. And as for priests who set themselves up
法国西部地区，叛军一直在有意识地试图阻止革命。他们把圣心佩戴在衣服上。他们在军事行动前参加弥撒。他们高呼上帝和国王作为战斗口号。罗伯斯庇尔绝不可能容忍这一点。因此，他完全认识到有必要让广大民众摆脱这种迷信，如果有必要，手段必须残酷。至于那些自立门户的牧师
against the revolution and preach to their flocks that God hates what Robespierre is doing, they are plainly beyond the pale. And as counter-revolutionaries, clearly they have to go to the guillotine. And sure enough, over the course of the terror, a thousand of these priests do go to the So there is nothing moderate about Robespierre's treatment of them there. There's something very Protestant about Robespierre, isn't that? So Protestant. I mean, there's something very Protestant about the whole wave of de-Christianisation, as we will see. You know, with church and state relationship between church and state, get rid of barbaric, backward superstitions, all of that sort of stuff.
还有那种对规则的严苛坚持，我认为这其中也有非常新教的东西。好吧，我的意思是，这可能是我之前提到过的一点，但我认为，即使是最激进的革命者，想要跳出那个国家几个世纪以来一直处于的基督教框架，也是非常困难的。你根本不可能在一夜之间做到。所以如果你看看罗伯斯庇尔，他的野心是看到基督教被至高存在崇拜所取代。但他的愿望的动力我认为是可以辨认出源于基督教的。而且我认为其中的新教元素显然非常强烈。你可以在罗伯斯庇尔为他的节日选择的日期上看到这一点，因为它是在最初的基督教五旬节那天。
And also the sort of austere insistence upon the rules, I think is something very protestant about that. Well, I mean, it's a point I may have made before, but I think it is so difficult, even for the most radical revolutionaries, to think themselves out of the box, the Christian box, that their country has been in for centuries and centuries and centuries. You're just impossible to do it overnight. And so if you look at Robs-Pierre, his ambition is to see Christianity replaced by the cult of the supreme being. but the dynamics of what he wants are recognizably bred of Christianity, I think. And I think the Protestant element of it is clearly, really strong. And you can see this manifest on the date that Rospier had chosen for his festival because it was on what originally was the Christian Feast Day of Pentecost.
它是故意设计来取代它的。但当然，如果你如此公开地取代某样东西，你在某种意义上是在向它致敬。取代基督教。我的意思是，显然大多数普通的法国男女会觉得这完全令人困惑和费解。但实际上，他们准备为了做到这一点而付出相当大的努力。而这方面的经典例子，人们对法国大革命最著名的事情之一，就是，我的意思是，我已经提到了历法。
It's deliberately designed to replace it. But of course, if you're replacing something that overtly, you are in a sense paying homage to it. replacing Christianity. I mean, obviously this is something that most ordinary French men and women would find completely bewildering and baffling. But actually, they are prepared to go to quite considerable lengths in order to do that. And the classic example of this, one of the most famous things that people know about the French Revolution, is the, I mean, I already mentioned the calendar.
人们根据基督教历法、节日、庆典、圣诞节、复活节、周日礼拜等等来构建他们的生活。如果你是一个法国农民，那就是赋予你生活意义和结构的东西。但革命现在说我们要废除所有这些。我们要发明一种全新的历法，而且我们，我的意思是，我们不会从零年开始，
People structure their lives by the Christian calendar, the feast days, the festivals, Christmas, Easter, Sunday services and so on and so forth. If you're a French peasant, that's what gives you a life. meaning and structure. But the revolution is now saying we're going to actually get rid of all that. We're going to invent an entirely new calendar and we are, I mean, we're not going to start with year zero,
但我们要从一年开始。是的，他们要开启一个全新的时间秩序。他们早在1793年10月5日就做到了这一点，当时公会在救国委员会的全力批准下，宣布基督教时代正式结束，年份不再从基督诞生开始计算，而是从法兰西共和国的第一天开始，也就是君主制被废除的那一天。
but we're going to start with year one. Yeah, they're going to inaugurate a completely new order of time. And they've done this back on the 5th of October 1793 when the convention with the full approval of the Committee of Public Safety they declare that the Christian era is officially at an end and that years will no longer be dated from the birth of Christ but instead from the first day of the French Republic so the day that the monarchy was abolished
所以在基督教历法中那是1792年9月22日，但被取代的不仅仅是年份，还有传统的月份名称。所以一种全新的年度历法被引入了。所以这一年现在以三个秋季月份开始。它们分别是葡月（Vendémiaire）、雾月（Brumaire）和霜月（Frimaire）。它们分别以法语中的葡萄收获、雾和冷命名。然后冬天你有雪月（Nivôse），以法语中的雪命名。
so that in the Christian calendar had been the 22nd of September 1792 but it's not just the years that have been replaced it's also the traditional names of months as well So a whole new kind of yearly calendar has been brought in. So the year now begins with three months of autumn. And these are Vondamillers, Bumere and Frimère. And these are named respectively after the French for the wine harvest, fog and cold. And then winter you have Nivos, so named after French for snow.
雨月（Pluviôse），雨，风月（Ventôse），风。春天，它发芽，有一个月叫芽月（Germinal）。它在花月（Floréal）开花，并在牧月（Prairial）蔓延到成熟的田野中。所以草原（prairie）是一种草地，不是吗？这就是草原的名字。然后在夏天，你有获月（Messidor），以收获命名，热月（Thermidor）以热命名，果月（Fructidor）以果实命名，当庄稼和水果完全成熟时。我认为这些名字很美，它们是一位我们已经见过的诗人和剧作家法布尔·德格朗坦（Fabre d'Églantine）的创作。是的，腐败，编造关于腐败的疯狂阴谋论，最后和丹东一起上了断头台。是的，它们的结构方式抹去了传统的基督教周。所以那种每七天一次的周日节奏消失了。所以它被完全抹去了。为了处理闰年之类的事情，他增加了五天额外的时间，他称之为——荒谬地——无套裤汉日（Sans-culottides）。所以无套裤汉日。
Pluvios, rain, vontoes, wind. Spring, it does. germinates with a month that is called geminal. It flowers in a month called florial, and it spreads through the ripening fields in prairieal. So prairie is a kind of meadow, isn't it? And it's the name prairie. And then in summer, you have Messido, named after the harvest, termidor named after heat, and fructidor fruition when the crops and the fruit are coming to full ripeness. I think they're beautiful names and they are the creation of a poet and a playwright whom we've already met, Fabre d'oglottein. Yeah, corrupt, making up mad conspiracy
是的，那是个糟糕的名字。我认为他在那方面让自己失望了，法布尔。他得走了。那么罗伯斯庇尔对此怎么看？他一点也不反对。事实上，他向公会提出了一项修正案，提议将这五个以巴黎穷人命名的无套裤汉日中的一天定为美德节。这项动议通过了。所以我可以看到你的脸因为想到一年一度的美德节而焕发出喜悦。这感觉太像萨迪克·汗（Sadiq Khan）了，不是吗？完全是。完全是。
theories about corruption and ending up with Donto on the guillotine. Yes, and the way they're structured wipes out the traditional Christian week. So that rhythm of Sundays every seventh day, that goes. So it's completely erased. And just to deal with kind of leap years and things, like that. He adds in five extra days, which he calls I mean ludicrously, son collotide. So son collot days.
萨迪克·汗和我们的女狮队将在特拉法加广场庆祝多元化。完全是。是的。这就是它的样子。而且，你知道，他在向公会宣布至高存在节的演讲中。他给出的日期不是传统的历法，所以不是1794年6月8日，
Yeah, that's a bad name. He's let himself down there, I think, Fab. He had to go. So what does Robespier think about this? He's not against it at all. In fact, he brings an amendment to the convention proposing that one of these
而是他说这将是共和二年牧月20日。很遗憾，到这个时候，埃格朗坦已经被送上断头台了，所以他没能享受他的历法被这个盛大的节日装饰的景象。对他来说太悲哀了。所以罗伯斯庇尔对历法没意见。他对此没问题。
sonculotid, these five days named after the poor of Harris should be enshrined as a festival of virtue. And this motion is passed. So I can see your face lighting up with joy at the thought of an annual festival of virtue. That feels so Sadiq Khan, doesn't it? Completely. Completely.
事实上，他很热心。但是去基督教化，我的意思是，去基督教化和去基督教化是不一样的。他对那些看起来，你知道，全是关于庆祝，你知道，包容性的东西感到高兴。德卡鲁斯（Decarus）。完全正确。然而，有很多去基督教化是他不喜欢的。这就是去基督教化变得更野蛮、更明显地倾向于破坏行为或粗俗的地方，我想。是的。
Sidney Khan and our lionesses will be celebrating diversity in Trafalgarious. Completely. Yeah. That's what it would be. And also, you know, at the speech he gives. to the convention announcing the festival of the supreme being. He gives the date not in the traditional calendar, so not on the 8th of June 1794,
或者确实是公开的暴力。他反对品味低劣，如果暴力与去基督教化联系在一起，他也反对。好吧，如果暴力不是集中的、受控的、基于规则的暴力，他是反对的。是的，不是基于规则的，是的，完全正确。所以你可以看到这体现在他摧毁埃贝尔（Hébert）和埃贝尔周围的去基督教化者的野心上。
but he says it's going to be the 20th of Praerial year two. And it's sad that by this point, Egleteen has been guillotined, so he's not around to enjoy the spectacle of his calendar being garnished with this great festival. So sad for him. So Rob's sure is okay with the calendar. He's fine with that.
但他不仅在首都，在各省也急于根除它。在这里，到1793年底，局势已经明确转向有利于革命。所以本质上，革命精英现在的任务是进行报复和惩罚。其中最臭名昭著的发生在旺代，这并不奇怪，因为那是危险最大的地方。
In fact, he's enthusiastic. But de-Christianisation, I mean, there's de-Christianisation, de-Christianisation. He's happy with something that appears, you know, that's all about celebrating, you know, inclusivity. Decarus. Exactly. However, there's a lot of de-Christianisation that he is not keen on. This is where de-Christianisation, where it is more feral, where it is more obviously tipping into vandalism or vulgarity, I suppose. Yes.
我们已经讨论过关于旺代伤亡数字的争议。但我认为即使是那些不会称之为种族灭绝的人也会承认，屠杀的程度非常大，也许是人口的三分之一。是的，三分之一到四分之一。我的意思是，一个巨大的数字。我的意思是，我们谈论的是成千上万的男人、女人和儿童。是的，因为其中许多是平民，他们并没有参与起义。
Or indeed, openly violent. and he's against Tasteless and he's against violence if it's tied up with de-Christianisation. Well, he's against violence if it is not centralised, controlled, rules-based violence. Yes, not rules-based, yes, exactly. So you could see that manifest in his ambition to destroy Abert and the de-Christianisers who are around A-Beer.
我认为巴黎革命者对此的看法是，你知道，如果偶尔有一个爱国者被误杀，那么，你知道，这是为了革命的利益而做出的牺牲，他们应该为能在那项事业中接受死亡而感到自豪。所以有一位将军在1794年初被派去平定旺代，他给他的部队下了这样的指示：“用你们的刺刀，消灭你们沿途遇到的所有居民。我知道这个地区可能有一些爱国者。没关系，我们必须把他们全部杀掉。”
But he's anxious to root it out in the provinces as well as in the capital. And here, by the end of 1793, the tide has definitely turned in favour of the revolution. And so essentially the task now for the revolutionary elites is to inflict reprisals and punishments. And the most notorious of these takes place unsurprisingly in the Vande and unsurprisingly because that was where the peril had been the greatest.
我们正在谈论革命中的基督教回响。那里有一个十字军战士曾经发表过的最臭名昭著的评论的回响。所以这是阿尔比十字军东征中的一位牧师，他被认为是一名基督徒，据说有人问他：“我们如何识别谁是异端，谁是好基督徒？”他回答说：“全部杀掉。上帝会认出他自己的人。”我认为那种精神显然在革命军队的高层中仍然非常活跃。我的意思是，那是会让罗伯斯庇尔感到恐惧的事情，你知道，他相信规则。但更让他恐惧的是个人实施的暴行，
And we've discussed the controversy around the casualty figures in the Vandei. But I think even those who would not apply the name of genocide to it would acknowledge that the degree of slaughter is very great, that perhaps a third of the population. Yeah, a third to a quarter. I mean, a colossal number of people. I mean, we're talking about hundreds of thousands of men, women and children. Yeah, because lots of these are civilians who are not participating in the uprising.
特别是那些被派往各省的代表，他们有点像库尔茨上校（Colonel Kurtz），被自己的权力冲昏了头脑，实际上放纵了他们更虐待狂的冲动。我的意思是，我会说是的，而在法国西部，他们实际上不在旺代，而是在南特地区，最臭名昭著的一个家伙叫让-巴蒂斯特·卡里耶（Jean-Baptiste Carrier）。
And I think the perspective on this of the revolutionaries in Paris is that, you know, if an occasional patriot is slain by mistake, then, you know, it's a sacrifice for the good of the, of the revolutionaries. revolution and they should be proud to accept their death in that cause. So there was a general who was sent to pacify the Vonday in early 1794, and he gave his troops these instructions, spare with your bayonets, all the inhabitants you encounter along the way. I know there may be a few patriots in this region. It matters not, we must kill them all.
让罗伯斯庇尔感到震惊的不仅是他的暴力，还有他的亵渎，罗伯斯庇尔认为这是完全没有必要的。所以关于让-巴蒂斯特·卡里耶的故事被历史学家争论。我的意思是，它们是反革命的宣传吗？其中一些可能是。但我认为很明显，在这种情况下，
And we're talking about the Christian echoes in the revolution. There's an echo there of one of the most notorious comments ever made by a crusader. So this was one of the priests in the Albigensian Crusade, who supposed to be a Christian, you supposedly was asked, how do we recognise who the heretic is and who the good Christian? And he answers, kill them all. God will know his own. And I think that that spirit is still clearly very much alive in the upper echelons of the revolutionary military. And I mean, that's the sort of thing that would horrify Rob Spierre, you know, who believes in the rules. But what horrifies him even more are the atrocities that are carried out by individuals,
没有火就没有烟。所以让我们列出关于卡里耶的报道。据说他把囚犯手脚捆绑装上驳船，这些驳船的底部被锯开了洞，然后塞住了。当这些驳船到达卢瓦尔河或其他河流的中间时，塞子被拔掉，守卫跳进小船，而那些手脚被束缚的人就沉入河中，全部淹死了。
particularly deputies who've been sent out to the provinces who sort of go a little bit Colonel Kurtz become drunk with their own power and effectively indulge their more sadistic urges I mean I would say yes and the most notorious of these in the west of France they're not actually in the Vonde but around the region of Nantes is a guy called Jean-Baptiste Carrier
卡里耶觉得把这些大规模溺水描述为“共和党洗礼”很有趣。所以那真是个巨大的玩笑。其中一些，如果是年轻人，他们可能被剥去了衣服，因为如果你是处理反革命分子的革命卫队，衣服是你得到的福利的一部分，所以男人和女人
and what appalls Robespierre about him is not just his violence but also his blasphemy which Rospiers sees is completely unnecessary. So the stories that are told about Jean-Martis Carrier are debated by historians. I mean, are they counter-revolutionary propaganda? Some of them may be. But I think it's evident that in this case
赤身裸体地被捆绑在一起面对面，这些被卡里耶描述为“共和党婚姻”，所以我猜你要么觉得这很有趣，要么不觉得。卡里耶显然认为这非常滑稽，而回到巴黎的罗伯斯庇尔，我的意思是，他一点也不觉得这很有趣。我的意思是，他这辈子从来没觉得什么东西有趣过。
there is no smoke without fire. So let's just list the things that are reported of Carrier. So it said that he loads prisoners with their hands and feet tied onto barges and that these barges have had holes soared in the bottom and then being plugged. And when these barges get out into the middle of the Loire or, you know, some other river, the plugs are pulled out, the guards leap into boats, and the people with their hands and legs fettered just sink into the river and are all drowned.
他绝对不会觉得这很有趣。不，这让他感到恶心。这就是为什么在1794年2月，他召回卡里耶回到巴黎，卡里耶处于极大的耻辱之中。但卡里耶并不是在各省的行为最让罗伯斯庇尔感到震惊的共和党特使。他真正严厉打击的家伙是里昂的共和党特使，也就是在法国南部，离旺代很远的地方。原因有二。
And Carrier, it amuses him to describe these mass drownings as Republican baptisms. So that's a massive banter there. And some of them, if they are young men or women, they might have been stripped of their clothing because clothes are part of the perks that you get if you're a revolutionary guard dealing with counter-revolutionaries and so the men and women
首先，他在里昂实施的亵渎和暴行特别有创造力、有想象力。但其次，这家伙是罗伯斯庇尔的老相识，事实上，曾短暂地追求过罗伯斯庇尔心爱的妹妹夏洛特。所以从这个程度上讲，这对罗伯斯庇尔来说是私人的。这家伙叫约瑟夫·富歇（Joseph Fouché），剧透预警，他将来会在拿破仑手下拥有漫长而杰出的职业生涯，担任他的警察局长。但目前，相对于罗伯斯庇尔，他当然不是一个重要角色。富歇最初来自法国西部，来自卢瓦尔河口的一个小渔港。
naked would then be bound facing one another and these were described by Carrier as Republican marriages so I guess you either find that funny or you don't Carier obviously thinks it's hilarious and Robespierre back in Paris I mean he's not amused by this at all I mean he's never found anything funny in his life
他曾受教于一个叫“演说会”（Oratorians）的宗教团体，这些家伙在法国各地经营学校。从这所学校毕业后，富歇留了下来，并作为物理老师为演说会工作。我想这比当体育老师还糟糕。不，这不像当体育老师那么糟糕，但绝对差不多。有人在那儿喋喋不休地讲质量、体积和密度之类的东西。
He's definitely not going to find this funny. No, it disgusts him. And this is why in February 1794, he summons Carrier back to Paris, and Carrier is in deep disgrace. But Carrier isn't the Republican agent whose behaviour in the provinces most appalls Robespierre. The guy who he really comes down on hard is the Republican agent in Lyon, so in the south of France a long way from the Vonday. And the reason for this is twofold.
太可怕了。摧毁灵魂。多米尼克，这要求他发小宗教誓言并穿上教士长袍。你刚才说很多革命者中存在反教权主义的倾向。我认为很多这些革命者，这里再次与宗教改革有相似之处，
Firstly, that the blasphemies and atrocities that he's perpetrating in Lyon are particularly creative, imaginative. But secondly, this guy is an old associate of Robespier's, and in fact, very briefly had been a suitor for the hand of Charlotte, Robespier's beloved sister. So to that extent, it's personal for Robespierre. And this is a guy called Joseph Foucher, who, spoiler alert, will have a long and distinguished career under Napoleon in due course as his chief of police. But at the moment, relative to Robs Pierre, certainly, he's not a significant player. Foucher had come originally from the west of France, from a small fishing port on the mouth of the Loire.
是那些自己曾是教士或与教士关系密切的人。当他们反教权时，他们知道自己在说什么。你知道，他们有亲身经历，因此他们对它的蔑视源于他们所经历的一切的源泉。我的意思是，这听起来太简化和陈腐了，
And he had been educated by a religious group called the Oratorians. and these were guys who ran schools across France. And after graduating in this school, Foucher had stayed on and he had worked for the oratorians as a physics teacher. That's worse than being a PE teacher, I think. No, it's not quite as bad as being a PE teacher, but it's definitely up there. Someone whittering on about mass, volume and density and stuff.
但源于挫折、羞辱、失望的期望等个人怨恨，所有这些东西。这就是驱动相当多这些人的动力。它驱动马拉，它驱动罗伯斯庇尔。你知道，富歇，你可以想象他是个物理老师。每个人都讨厌物理老师。而演说会里的其他人，谁知道呢？他可能对他们怀有某种怨恨。
Awful. Soul destroying. Dominic, this had required him to take minor religious vows and wear a clerical robe. And you were saying how the vein of anti-clericalism among a lot of the revolutionaries. I think a lot of these revolutionaries, and again, there's a parallel here with the Reformation,
他们以某种方式贬低了他，他想“总有一天我会让你好看”。现在因为革命，他有了机会。是的，都同意。还有另一种可能性，添加到混合中的另一件事是，他是一名物理老师，而自然哲学家在这一点上非常突出，开始将天主教视为迷信。
are people who themselves had been clerics or had been clerically adjacent? That they, when they are anti-clerical, they know whereof they speak. You know, they've had personal experience of it, and therefore their contempt for it comes from the wellsprings of everything they've been through. I mean, it sounds so reductive and a banal of points,
所以他教授的学科和每天参加10次礼拜之类的要求之间可能存在紧张关系。所以这可能也是一部分。我们不知道。是的，我的意思是，他可能在摆弄磁铁。是的。或者，嗯，风箱。
but personal resentment, born of frustration, humiliation, disappointed expectations, all of those kinds of things. That's what drives quite a lot of these people. It drives Mara, it drives Rob Spierre. You know, Fusha, you can imagine he's a physics teacher. Everyone hates a physics teacher. And the other people in the kind of oratorian order, you know, who knows? He maybe burns with some resentment of them.
是的。所以很明显，到1788年，他去了阿拉斯，显然是罗伯斯庇尔和他妹妹的家乡。他那时已经开始对激进政治产生兴趣了。正是在阿拉斯，也就是罗伯斯庇尔的家乡，他遇到了“不可腐蚀者”。他开始了对夏洛特的追求。而夏洛特，给她点赞，她从一开始就认出了他。是一个坏蛋。她对她哥哥说：“他追求我只是因为他认为这是进入你感情的一种方式。”
They put him down in some way and he thinks one day I'll show you. And now he's got the opportunity because of the revolution. Yeah, all agreed. and another possibility, something else to add into the mix, is that he is a physics teacher and natural philosophers at this point are very prominent in coming to view Catholicism as superstition.
所以她和他没有任何关系。所以当革命开始时，罗伯斯庇尔去了巴黎。富歇没有，他没有作为代表去。所以他们两三年没见面了。但到了1792年，他们的相识又恢复了，因为此时富歇已经被选为代表，他抵达巴黎，在那里他投票支持处决路易十六。
And so there may be a tension between the discipline that he's teaching and the requirement to go in 10 services every day or something like that. So that might be part of us well. We don't know. Yeah, I mean, he could be messing around with magnets. Yes. Or, well, bellows.
到1793年，他已经成为雅各宾俱乐部的相当重要的成员。你知道，他开始为自己赢得名声。他正是你从物理老师那里所期望的那样，多米尼克。所以他很冷漠。他很理智。他很自控。他是一个通常在阴影中繁荣的人。他受到雅各宾俱乐部激进分子的钦佩，
Yeah. So it's clear that already by 1788, he goes to Arras, the home, obviously, of Robsbier and his sister. And he is already starting to take an interest in radical politics then. And it's in Arras, so the hometown of Robsbier, that he meets with The Incorruptible. He embarks on his courtship of Charlotte. And Charlotte, to give her credit, she identifies him. as a wrongen right from the start. She says to her brother, he's only after me because he thinks it's a way to
因为他的狂热热情、他的能力以及他会为事业做任何事的普遍感觉。我必须说，我认为富歇是一个相当严肃的人，
get into your affections. And so she has nothing to do with him. So when the revolution starts, Rochevier goes to Paris. Foucher doesn't, he doesn't go as a deputy. And so they don't see each other for a couple of years, two or three years. But then in 1792, their acquaintance is renewed because by now Foucher has been elected as a deputy and he arrives in Paris where he votes for the execution. of Louis the 16th.
即使他是个物理老师。好吧，我的意思是，他正在从物理教学中毕业。他正在转向其他事情。是的，我知道他快要让自己失望并表现糟糕了，但有时你必须坚强。我的意思是，也许对于无套裤汉来说，他不会表现糟糕。
And by 1793, he has become a fairly prominent member of the Shakabang Club. You know, he's starting to make a name for himself. And he is exactly what you would expect from a physics teacher, Dominic. So he is cold. He is cerebral. He is self-controlled. And he is a man generally who flourishes in the shadows. And he is, he's admired by,
也许他只是在做需要做的事情。我的意思是，我们可以讨论。我们不能做煎蛋卷之类的。这是为了介绍他在各省的记录。所以1793年夏天，这是革命看起来普遍似乎背水一战的时候。法国正在内爆，所有这些。他被派去处理涅夫勒（Nièvre）地区的反革命行为，该地区位于巴黎和里昂之间。他在那里的任务是镇压可能存在的反革命活动，
radicals in the Jacquan club for his fanatical zeal and for his ability and for the general sense that he will do anything for the cause. I have to say, I think Foucher is quite a serious person
征用粮食，并让当地人为即将到来的大规模征兵做好准备。富歇非常有效地完成了所有这些，但他还利用机会开始了法国所见过的第一次系统性的去基督教化运动。所以这在埃贝尔在巴黎搞任何事情之前。这是第一次尝试。而富歇，他显然在为演说会工作的多年里积累了很多怨恨，他强迫牧师放弃誓言。他关闭、亵渎、重新利用教堂。
even though he's a physics teacher. Okay, well, he's, I mean, he's graduating from the physics teaching lock. He's moving on to other things. Yeah, I know he's about to let himself down and behave badly, but sometimes you've got to be robust. I mean, perhaps by the Sanbrook lights, he's not going to behave badly.
他剥夺了它们的金银，并把它们全部送到巴黎去资助战争。他没有进行弥撒，而是变得非常非常人文主义，非常理查德·道金斯（Richard Dawkins）。理性崇拜。致力于理性的崇拜。我们不会有迷信。我们将有致力于理性的崇拜。我的意思是，这本身并不疯狂迷信。在涅夫勒各地的墓地门口，他刻下了一条非常著名的信息，这是一种杀气腾腾的道金斯主义，我想。“死亡是永恒的睡眠。”他认为这太棒了。
perhaps he's just doing what needs to be done. I mean, we can discuss. We can't make an omelet and all that. This is by way of introducing his record in the provinces. So in the summer of 1793, this is at a point where the revolution generally seems to be, you know, it's back against the wall. France is imploding, all of that. He gets sent out to deal with counter-revolutionary behavior in a region called Nievre, which is midway between Paris and Lyon. and his mission there is to stamp down such counter-revolutionary activity as there may be,
你不会从这回来。你什么都不是，你是尘土。这就像理查德·道金斯贴在他巴士上的东西。你知道，“没有上帝，克服它”之类的。我想这大概是那个意思。此时，菲利普·普尔曼（Philip Pullman）正在听这个，并擦去喜悦的泪水。是的，完全正确。这有多大影响力的衡量标准是它为富歇在巴黎赢得的声誉。
to requisition grain and to ready the locals for this mass conscription, which is hoving into view. And Foucher does all this very effectively, but he also takes his opportunity to embark on what is at this point the first systematic campaign of de-Christianisation that France has seen. So this is before anything that Abert is getting up to in Paris. This is the first attempt. And Foucher, who clearly has a lot of resentment that has built up over his years working for the oratorians, he forces priests to renounce their vows. He closes, desecrates, repurposes churches.
它成为埃贝尔和他的直属上司、巴黎公社的肖梅特（Chaumette）发起的去基督教化运动的直接影响。在他从涅夫勒回来后，它也为他赢得了更重要的职位，那就是对里昂市进行报复的工作，因为它竟敢分裂公会。
He strips them of their gold and silver, and he sends it all to off. to Paris to fund the war. In place of the mass, he goes kind of very, very humanist, very Richard Dawkins. Cult of reason. Cults devoted to reason. We're not going to have superstition. We're going to have cults devoted to reason. I mean, like that's not madly superstitious in its own right. And on the gateways of cemeteries across Nieveh, he inscribes a very famous message, which is a kind of murderous Dawkinsism, I guess. Death is an eternal sleep. And he thinks this is brilliant.
所以这在我们之前的剧集中一直是一个隆隆作响的主题，不是吗？里昂，法国的第二大城市，竟敢反对巴黎革命政府的指令，因此需要被树立为一个榜样。巴黎的政府认为富歇正是做这件事的人。他显然很出色。所以富歇于1793年11月10日抵达里昂，他以非常新教的风格开始了事情，尽管他不会那样看，用一场公开的弥撒模仿秀。
You're not coming back from this. You're nothing, you're dust. It was like the thing that Richard Dawkins put up on his bus. You know, there's no God get over it or something. I think it was kind of along those lines. At this point, like Philip Pullman's listening to this and wiping away tears of joy. Yeah, exactly. And the measure of how influential this is is the renown that it wins Foucher back in Paris.
你回不来了。你什么都不是，你只是尘埃。这就像理查德·道金斯在他巴士上写的那样。你知道，大概是“没有上帝，接受现实吧”之类的。我觉得差不多就是这个意思。此时此刻，菲利普·普尔曼听了这些，大概正在擦拭喜悦的泪水。是的，没错。而这有多大影响力，可以从富歇回到巴黎后所获得的声望中看出来。
And it becomes a direct influence on the campaign of de-Christianization that that Abert and Schomet, his immediate superior in the Paris Commune, the one that the campaign that they launch. And it also wins him a much more significant posting after he's come back from Nievere, which is the job of taking vengeance on the city of Lyon for having dared to divide the convention.
这直接影响了埃贝尔和他的巴黎公社直属上司肖梅特所发起的去基督教化运动。这也为他从涅夫勒回来后赢得了一个更重要的职位，那就是对里昂市进行报复，因为该市竟敢分裂国民公会。
So this has been a kind of rumbling theme in the background of our previous episode, hasn't it? The fact that Leon, the second city in France, had dared to oppose. the dictates of the revolutionary government in Paris and therefore needs to be made an example of. And the government in Paris thinks Foucher is just the guy for this. He's clearly brilliant. And so Foucher arrives in Lyon on the 10th of November, 1793, and he kicks things off in very Protestant style, although that's not how he would have seen it with a public parody of the mass.
所以这在我们上一集里一直是一个隐约的主题，不是吗？里昂，作为法国第二大城市，竟敢反对巴黎革命政府的指令，因此需要被树立为反面典型。巴黎政府认为富歇正是执行此任务的最佳人选。他显然才华横溢。于是，富歇于1793年11月10日抵达里昂，并以一种非常新教徒的风格开启了行动，尽管他自己可能并不这么认为，那就是举行了一场公开的弥撒讽刺剧。
So there's a lot of smashing of icons. There's kind of usual Protestant shenanigans with donkeys wearing mitres, dragging Bibles and crucifixes by its tail, all of this, great stuff. Very hard to tell the difference there between what the Anabaptists were getting up to and what the revolutionaries are getting up to. And he then follows it up with a series of atrocities that become notorious across France. And what Foucher does, he feels that the guillotine isn't quick enough. There are too many counter-revolutionaries who need dealing with. he introduces efficiency savings and he ties up 60 young people together, chains them up, leads them outside the city where there's a row of cannon and he then blasts them with grape shot.
所以当时有很多破坏偶像的行为。还有一些通常的新教徒恶作剧，比如让驴子戴上主教冠，拖着圣经和十字架，诸如此类，非常精彩。很难分辨出重洗派在做什么，革命者又在做什么。随后，他实施了一系列在法国臭名昭著的暴行。富歇觉得断头台不够快，有太多的反革命分子需要处理。于是他引入了效率提升措施，将60名年轻人捆绑在一起，用铁链锁住，带到城外一排大炮前，然后用葡萄弹将他们轰杀。
And most of them initially are not dead. They're kind of left mutilated, screaming, guts spilling out of their stomachs, whatever, absolute carnage. And so they then have to be finished off by cavalrymen who gallop in with their drawn sabers. and trample them down and, you know, stick them with their sabres and finish it that way. Yeah. So it's not actually that efficient after all. I guess you could say that, but Foucher is trying to learn.
起初，他们中的大多数人并没有死。他们被炸得残缺不全，尖叫着，肠子流出体外，总之，场面极其惨烈。因此，他们必须由骑兵来补刀，骑兵们拔出马刀冲进来，将他们践踏在地，用马刀刺死他们，以此结束他们的生命。是的，所以这实际上并没有那么高效。我想你可以这么说，但富歇正在学习。
And so the following day, he does it with 210 young people. And I do like the emphasis and the sources that it's young people. Again, Foucher may be working off his resentment of the students that he'd had to teach. I don't know. Is the Douglas Haig of French Revolutionary reprisals sort of. of commanders. You know, he's learning from, he's learning and he's throwing more and more people into it the next time. And one day, he'll finally reach the efficient breakthrough that he's looking for. I'm apologising to Gary Sheffield, the great historian of Douglas Haig, if he's
第二天，他用210名年轻人如法炮制。我确实很喜欢资料中对“年轻人”这一点的强调。同样，富歇可能是在发泄他对曾经教过的学生的怨恨。我不知道。他算是法国大革命报复行动中的道格拉斯·黑格（Douglas Haig）式指挥官吗？你知道，他正在学习，而且下一次他投入了越来越多的人。总有一天，他会达到他所追求的高效突破。如果加里·谢菲尔德（Gary Sheffield），那位伟大的道格拉斯·黑格历史学家，正在
listening to that, I am not associating myself with that comment at all. Basically, does Douglas Haig learn? I don't know, we'll be getting on to that in our next series on the First World War, I guess. But definitely Fouché has learned because this time the, the canon are aimed much more effectively. And so the deaths are much more instantaneous. And these kind of executions continue for months. And by April 1794, Foucher has been responsible for over 2,000 deaths. And we know that that's accurate because he's keeping a very precise account of everyone he's killed. And he thinks, you know, he sees nothing to apologize here. He thinks that he is serving the revolution. And so he exalts terror, salitary terror is now the order of the day here. We are causing much
听这段话，我完全不认同那个评论。基本上，道格拉斯·黑格学到了吗？我不知道，我想我们会在下一期关于第一次世界大战的系列节目中讨论这个问题。但富歇肯定学到了，因为这一次，大炮瞄准得更有效了。所以死亡发生得更瞬间。这种处决持续了几个月。到1794年4月，富歇已经造成了超过2000人死亡。我们知道这个数字是准确的，因为他对自己杀死的每一个人都做了非常精确的记录。他认为，你知道，他觉得没什么可道歉的。他认为他是在为革命服务。于是他推崇恐怖，所谓的恐怖现在成了当下的秩序。我们正在导致许多
impure blood to flow, but it is our duty to do so. It is for the sake of humanity. But Robespierre, back in Paris, he doesn't agree at all. So those lines are a chilling foreshadowing of what, you know, the Nazis said about their own behaviour in the 1940s. We're doing this for the sake of the human race. Yeah, or whoever. But of course, listeners may think, well, Robespierre,
不纯的血液流淌，但这是我们的职责。这是为了人类的利益。但是远在巴黎的罗伯斯庇尔，他一点也不赞同。所以这些话是对纳粹在20世纪40年代对自己行为所作所为的令人不寒而栗的预示。我们这样做是为了人类。是的，或者其他什么人。但当然，听众可能会想，好吧，罗伯斯庇尔，
who is horrified and disgusted by these reports, says this is absolutely abhorrent to behave in this barbaric and sadistic way. But you might say, what is the difference? I mean, the only difference is that Foucher is using a different method. You're also killing hundreds and thousands of people, but you say, you know, oh, it's different because it's the guillotine and it's ordered. And here you come back, I suppose, to Rob Spier and the rules. He thinks, well, I follow the rules.
他对这些报告感到震惊和厌恶，说这种野蛮和虐待狂的行为绝对令人憎恶。但你可能会说，有什么区别呢？我的意思是，唯一的区别是富歇使用了不同的方法。你也在杀害成百上千的人，但你说，你知道，哦，这不一样，因为这是断头台，而且是合法的。我想，在这里你又回到了罗伯斯庇尔和规则的问题上。他认为，好吧，我遵守规则。
Yeah, he's not following the rules. He's not following the rules. So he talks about this with Charles. his sister, you know, who Foucher had once courted. And they agree that, to quote Charlotte, Fouche was a hypocritical, treacherous man without convictions, without morality, capable to doing anything to satisfy his wild ambition. He's not following the rules.
是的，他没有遵守规则。他没有遵守规则。所以他与夏洛特谈论这件事，他的妹妹，你知道，富歇曾经追求过她。他们一致认为，引用夏洛特的话，富歇是一个虚伪、背信弃义的人，没有信念，没有道德，为了满足他狂野的野心，什么事都做得出来。他没有遵守规则。
He's doing it because he enjoys it. He's not doing it because it is prescribed by the dictates of revolutionary virtue. It's as simple as that. That's what separates Robs-Pier from Foucher in Robs-Pier's own opinion. And it is sufficient to have Foucher summoned back to Paris. So on the 3rd of April, he sets off from Leon, someone back by the Committee of Public Safety, and the journey takes him five days.
他这样做是因为他乐在其中。他这样做并不是因为革命美德的准则所规定的。就是这么简单。这就是罗伯斯庇尔在罗伯斯庇尔自己看来与富歇的区别。这就足以让富歇被召回巴黎了。于是，4月3日，他从里昂出发，被公安委员会召回，旅程花了五天时间。
And, you know, this is a mad time to be arriving, if you're a notorious de-Christianizer in Paris, because this is in the middle of Rovst Pierre's elimination of Ebert and his gang. And you could easily imagine that Foucher might have been caught up in this. He isn't. And one of the reasons for this is that he starts to play a very daring and brilliant game.
而且，你知道，如果你是一个臭名昭著的去基督教化者，现在抵达巴黎是一个疯狂的时刻，因为这正处于罗伯斯庇尔清洗埃贝尔及其团伙的过程中。你可以很容易地想象富歇可能被卷入其中。但他没有。原因之一是他开始玩一场非常大胆而精彩的游戏。
So first of all, he arrives in Paris and rather than wait to be summoned by the convention to answer for what he's been getting up to, he goes there directly, he gets given the floor by the president, and he says, this is everything I've done. I'm unapologetic. I've done it for the revolution. He emphasises the fact that it's a virtuous terror, and who's to complain about that? And then he goes to see Rothpierre in his own private apartments, you know, in his Spartan little room. Robespier tears a strip off Foucher and Fouche comes out, you know, feeling pretty nervous. I mean, it's a bold move. It's a punchy move. And I think it kind of unsettles Robespier. He thinks, maybe this is more of a player than I'd appreciated. Yeah. Well, we'll see next time, actually, as we reach the final weeks of the terror. Political ability, boldness, seizing the moment and making the right call makes a massive difference.
所以首先，他抵达巴黎，并没有等待国民公会传唤他去为自己的所作所为负责，而是直接去了那里，主席给了他发言权，他说，这就是我所做的一切。我毫不后悔。我是为了革命而做的。他强调了这是一种正义的恐怖，谁能对此抱怨呢？然后他去罗伯斯庇尔的私人公寓见他，你知道，在他那个斯巴达式的小房间里。罗伯斯庇尔把富歇痛骂了一顿，富歇出来时，你知道，感觉相当紧张。我的意思是，这是一个大胆的举动。这是一个强有力的举动。我认为这让罗伯斯庇尔感到不安。他想，也许这家伙比我预想的更难对付。是的。好吧，下次我们再看，实际上，当我们进入恐怖统治的最后几周时。政治能力、胆识、抓住时机并做出正确的决定会产生巨大的
difference to your, you know, it really does come down to kind of political skill. And Foucher has played a blinder here. If he'd waited for them to come to him, he'd probably have been destined for the job. But by taking the initiative, putting himself out there, getting his story out, he has, he's wrong-footed Rob Speer, I think. Yeah, he sees the initiative. And this is what he does even more brilliantly on the 6th of June. So this is two days before the festival of the Supreme Breying.
差异，你知道，这确实归结为一种政治技巧。富歇在这里下了一步好棋。如果他等着他们来找他，他可能注定要被处决。但通过采取主动，让自己站出来，把自己的故事说出来，我认为他让罗伯斯庇尔措手不及。是的，他抓住了主动权。而他在6月6日做得更出色。所以这是在最高主宰节的前两天。
when he pulls an absolute blinder because not only does he stand as election for president of the Jacoban Club he wins it. Absolutely massive result and Robespierre of course is outraged and decides well I've got to take him down now you know this is a direct challenge so two days after the festival of the supreme being
当他下了一步绝对的好棋时，因为他不仅竞选雅各宾俱乐部主席，而且还赢了。绝对巨大的结果，罗伯斯庇尔当然感到愤怒，并决定，好吧，我现在必须除掉他，你知道，这是一个直接的挑战，所以就在最高主宰节两天后
on the 10th of June as it was the 22nd of Prairieal as it is now under the revolutionary calendar Robespierre kind of promotes a new law, and this is probably the most notorious law of the entire French Revolution. So it's called the Law of Prairielle. And it was formally proposed by George Couton, one of Rodsfier's closest to allies, but it had basically been written up by Robespier himself. And by its terms, the right of suspects to a defense lawyer was abolished. So that's a big, big step.
在6月10日，也就是革命历下的牧月22日，罗伯斯庇尔推动了一项新法律，这可能是整个法国大革命中最臭名昭著的法律。它被称为牧月法令。它是由罗伯斯庇尔最亲密的盟友之一乔治·库东正式提出的，但基本上是由罗伯斯庇尔本人起草的。根据其条款，嫌疑人拥有辩护律师的权利被废除了。所以这是一个非常大的步骤。
Plus the need for evidential testimony. So basically, you don't need annoying things like facts, evidence to prove the guilt of someone who is being arraigned. If the jurors feel in their hearts that this guy is an enemy, a wrongan, then that's enough. and this was actually something that Rob Speer had tried out with the Girondin because the trial with the Girondin had been going quite well and he basically said to the jurors, look, if you feel that they're guilty, that's enough, condemn them. And he's now instituting this and so he's bringing in the rules.
加上对证据证词的需求。所以基本上，你不需要像事实、证据这样烦人的东西来证明被传讯者的罪行。如果陪审员在心中觉得这家伙是个敌人，是个坏蛋，那就足够了。这实际上是罗伯斯庇尔在吉伦特派身上尝试过的东西，因为吉伦特派的审判进行得相当顺利，他基本上对陪审员说，看，如果你觉得他们有罪，这就足够了，判决他们。他现在正在实施这一点，所以他正在引入规则。
I mean, again, it's the point that you keep making. At the trial of Danton, I mean, again, they changed the rules halfway through, but it's important that there are rules. And at the end of that trial of Dantone, the prosecutor Fouqueton, said to the jury, forget about what you've heard and about the evidence. The question is very simple. Do you feel in your heart that Dantan is guilty?
我的意思是，这又是你一直强调的观点。在丹东的审判中，我的意思是，他们中途改变了规则，但重要的是有规则。在丹东审判结束时，检察官富基耶-坦维尔对陪审团说，忘记你所听到的和证据吧。问题很简单。你心中是否觉得丹东有罪？
And that's what they're now saying, isn't it? But what I think even more chilling about this, is not just that you don't get legal representation and they don't need any evidence to convict you. It is that you can be charged effectively for anything, because anything makes you an enemy of the people. Yeah, and this is exactly it, that enemy of the people becomes a new category of criminal under this law.
这就是他们现在所说的，不是吗？但我认为更令人不寒而栗的是，不仅仅是你没有法律代表，他们也不需要任何证据来定罪。而是你实际上可以因为任何事情被指控，因为任何事情都会让你成为人民的敌人。是的，这正是重点，人民的敌人成了这项法律下的一种新的罪犯类别。
So to quote it, those who in any manner and no matter with what mask they have concealed themselves has sought to thwart the progress of the revolution and prevent the strengthening of the republic. And that has Rovier's fingerprints all over it. He's so frustrated by people who display the show of virtue that he needs to create a criminal category that is capable of dealing with it. And so what that means in practice, I'll quote what risker lists the category of people who are now subject to potentially capital punishment. Anyone seeking to re-establish monarchy, discredit the convention, betray the Republic, communicate with foreign enemies, interfere with food provision, shelter conspirators, speak ill of patriotism, corrupt officials, mislead the people, spread false news, insult morality, deprave the public conscience, steal public property, abuse public office or plot against the liberty, unity and security of the state. For those found guilty, there is only the one sentence death, and basically that is a sufficiently flexible array of categories that you can bring it against. anyone. Well, who has not, you know, spread false news or spoken ill of public officials or
所以引用它的话，那些以任何方式，无论戴着什么面具隐藏自己，试图阻挠革命进程并阻止共和国加强的人。这上面到处都是罗伯斯庇尔的指纹。他对那些表现出美德的人感到非常沮丧，以至于他需要创造一个能够处理这种情况的犯罪类别。所以这意味着在实践中，我将引用罗伯斯庇尔列出的现在可能受到死刑处罚的人的类别。任何试图恢复君主制、诋毁国民公会、背叛共和国、与外国敌人勾结、干扰粮食供应、窝藏阴谋者、诋毁爱国主义、腐蚀官员、误导人民、散布虚假新闻、侮辱道德、败坏公共良知、窃取公共财产、滥用公职或密谋反对国家自由、统一和安全的人。对于被判有罪的人，只有一种判决：死刑，基本上这是一个足够灵活的类别数组，你可以用它来对付任何人。好吧，谁没有，你知道，散布过虚假新闻或诋毁过公职人员或
spoken ill of their country or whatever. Yeah, you know, especially you don't have to have defence lawyers or actually any evidence. Yeah, you also don't need any evidence that they've done it. You know, you can basically go after anyone. And so the day after he's introduced this, Robespierre turns on fuchsie and he goes to the jacquant club and he denounces foucher as a, I quote, base and contemptible cheat, and he issued a very blunt warning. I have made these remarks only say that the conspirators know once and for all that they will not escape the people's vengeance, and he does not say who he thinks the conspirators are. So essentially anyone listening to him might start thinking, am I a conspirator? Or does Rojpiers think I'm a conspirator? And so the
诋毁过他们的国家之类的。是的，你知道，特别是你不需要辩护律师，甚至不需要任何证据。是的，你也不需要任何证据证明他们做了。你知道，你基本上可以针对任何人。所以在他引入这个法律的第二天，罗伯斯庇尔转向了富歇，他去了雅各宾俱乐部，谴责富歇是一个，我引用，卑鄙和可鄙的骗子，并发出了一个非常直白的警告。我发表这些言论只是为了让阴谋者们一劳永逸地知道，他们将无法逃脱人民的惩罚，而且他没有说他认为阴谋者是谁。所以基本上任何听他说话的人都可能开始想，我是阴谋者吗？或者罗伯斯庇尔认为我是阴谋者吗？所以
Jacabin, who are aware of this, aware that this law could be turned against them at any point, They duly stripped Fouchet of his presidency, and they expel him from the Jacoban Club. And the following day, Rospier goes to the convention, and again, he speaks darkly of conspiracies. Again, he warns of terrible punishments. And again, as in the Jacoban Club, so now in the convention, those who listen to Rosbier, the deputies who are sitting there, are painfully aware that this law is hanging over their necks like the blade of a guillotine, and that it might be brought to drop at any moment. and Turio, you know, when he'd been sitting at the feet of Robespierre on the Papiomache Mountain,
雅各宾派，他们意识到这一点，意识到这项法律随时可能被用来对付他们，他们适时地剥夺了富歇的主席职位，并将他逐出雅各宾俱乐部。第二天，罗伯斯庇尔去了国民公会，再次阴暗地谈论阴谋。他再次警告会有可怕的惩罚。而且再次像在雅各宾俱乐部一样，现在在国民公会，那些听罗伯斯庇尔说话的人，坐在那里的代表们，痛苦地意识到这项法律像断头台的刀刃一样悬在他们的脖子上，随时可能落下。而图里奥，你知道，当他坐在罗伯斯庇尔脚下的山岳派时，
he had muttered contemptuously that Robespierre wanted to be God. And meanwhile, Robespierre himself, only a few hours earlier at the speech at the Festival of Supreme Being, had to find what he meant by God. It is he who instills remorse and terror in the bosom of the triumph and depressor and tranquility and pride in the heart of the innocent. And Robespierre's ambition, as it had always been, was to fulfil the purpose of this supreme being, to fulfil the purpose of God as Robespier understand him, and thereby to fill the revolution. But increasingly the paradoxes, the tragedy, I guess, is that the more he tries to do this, the more blood he is spilling.
他曾轻蔑地嘟囔说罗伯斯庇尔想成为上帝。与此同时，罗伯斯庇尔本人在几个小时前在最高主宰节的演讲中，定义了他所说的上帝是什么意思。是他，在胜利的压迫者心中灌输悔恨和恐怖，在无辜者的心中灌输宁静和骄傲。罗伯斯庇尔的野心，正如他一直以来的那样，是实现这个最高主宰的目的，实现罗伯斯庇尔所理解的上帝的目的，从而实现革命。但越来越大的悖论，我想，悲剧在于，他越是试图这样做，他流下的血就越多。
And as the final days of Paryal slipped by and then the days of Messidor, so the guillotine is, is being drawn up and dropped faster and faster and faster more and more relentlessly. And you can see this in the list of the people who are now being condemned to the guillotine. So a widow condemned for betraying the revolution to the English. A 70-year-old seamstress for quote-unquote various conspiracies. They're not listed. A tailor who's only 19 years old for soaring down a liberty tree. A vintner.
随着牧月的最后几天溜走，然后是热月，断头台被拉起并落下的速度越来越快，越来越无情。你可以从现在被判处断头台的人的名单中看到这一点。一个因背叛革命投靠英国人而被判刑的寡妇。一个70岁的女裁缝，因为所谓的“各种阴谋”。它们没有被列出。一个只有19岁的裁缝，因为锯倒了一棵自由树。一个酒商。
This is brilliant. for producing sour wine injurious to the health of citizens. To be fair, the vina had to go. But yeah, you're absolutely right, and I think that's the most chilling thing about it. So often when we talk about the French Revolution, we focus on the big names, Dantan, Ebert, Marie Antoinette, Charlotte Gorday, whoever. But actually, this is the point that's probably the most frightening because this is ordinary people who are being denounced by their neighbours
这太精彩了。因为生产损害公民健康的酸酒。公平地说，那个酒商必须走。但是的，你是完全正确的，我认为这是最令人不寒而栗的事情。当我们谈论法国大革命时，我们经常关注大人物，丹东、埃贝尔、玛丽·安托瓦内特、夏洛特·科黛等等。但实际上，这才是最可怕的一点，因为这是普通人被他们的邻居举报
for the most foothling and trivial offences, if they are offences. scores being settled, you know, the police state in operation, and Robespierre, because in some ways he is so unworldly, simply does not understand the implications, I think, of what he is doing, because he does not recognise the reality of human nature. You say he's unworldly. I think in lots of ways he isn't. I mean, he's a brilliant politician.
因为最琐碎和微不足道的罪行，如果它们算是罪行的话。旧账被清算，你知道，警察国家在运作，而罗伯斯庇尔，因为他在某些方面太不谙世事，我认为他根本不明白他所做的事情的含义，因为他不承认人性的现实。你说他不谙世事。我认为在很多方面他不是。我的意思是，他是一位出色的政治家。
He's outsmarted the Girondin. He's outsmarted, Ebert. He's outsmarted d'Anton. I think, however, by this point, you know, he is the victim of his own virtue. I think he's losing it. On his brilliant political skills, he's a very good politician until he isn't. And then he isn't in a very catastrophic and self-destructive way.
他智胜了吉伦特派。他智胜了埃贝尔。他智胜了丹东。然而，我认为到这一点，你知道，他是他自己美德的受害者。我认为他正在失去理智。在他出色的政治技巧方面，他是一位非常好的政治家，直到他不再是。然后他以一种非常灾难性和自我毁灭的方式不再是了。
I mean, he is not behaving wisely by this point. Because, of course, you know, if Bintas are being executed because they're making bad wine, what about someone like Foucher? He must know he's a marked man. And so he does what he always does, which is to go on the offensive while operating in the shadows. Because he knows that there are large numbers of deputies who are very, very worried about whether they will be on the face of the earth for long. And some of these are now, I think, increasingly prepared to give Fouchet an ear and other people like Foucher. People who like Foucher feel that they are marked men.
我的意思是，到这一点，他的行为并不明智。因为，当然，你知道，如果酒商因为酿造劣质酒而被处决，那么像富歇这样的人呢？他一定知道自己是个被盯上的人。所以他做了他一贯做的事，那就是在阴影中运作的同时发起进攻。因为他知道有大量的代表非常非常担心他们是否还能在这个世界上活多久。而其中一些人现在，我认为，越来越准备听取富歇和其他像富歇一样的人的意见。那些像富歇一样觉得他们是被盯上的人。
But I mean, I suppose the question is, how do you, what do you do when faced with someone like Rospier? You know, is it going to be possible to bring him down? And these questions are hanging in the air as the days continue to pass. And the month of Messador gives way to the month of Termidor. Well, Termador means heat, doesn't it? And for Robsbier, for the terror, for the people of Paris, and indeed for the French Revolution, things are about to get very hot indeed. So in our next episode, the final episode of this series, The Fall of Rob Spear,
但我认为问题是，当你面对像罗伯斯庇尔这样的人时，你该怎么办？你知道，有可能打倒他吗？随着日子一天天过去，这些问题悬在空中。牧月让位于热月。好吧，热月意味着热，不是吗？对于罗伯斯庇尔，对于恐怖，对于巴黎人民，甚至对于法国大革命，事情即将变得非常火热。所以，在我们的下一集，本系列的最后一集，罗伯斯庇尔的倒台，
a story of extraordinarily melodramatic twists. So a lot to come. Now, if you remember, the rest is history club, our own atheistical sect, then you will surely want to listen to that episode right away. If you're not a member of the club, this really is the time to join. If you don't join now, you're a lost cause, Frank. You were completely lost course. Catervolutionary, I would say.
一个充满极其夸张转折的故事。所以有很多内容即将到来。现在，如果你记得“其余皆是历史”俱乐部，我们自己的无神论教派，那么你肯定会想立刻听那一集。如果你不是俱乐部的成员，现在真的是加入的时候了。如果你现在不加入，你就是一个无可救药的人，弗兰克。你完全无可救药。我会说，反革命分子。
Deserving death. I think, yeah. The guillotine is the only language you understand. So join the Restis History Club. The Republic of Virtue awaits. And we will see you next time for the fall of Robespierre. A-bye. Bye-bye.
罪该万死。我想，是的。断头台是你唯一能听懂的语言。所以加入“其余皆是历史”俱乐部吧。美德共和国在等待着。我们下次见，讨论罗伯斯庇尔的倒台。再见。再见。
Is history anything more than the story of heroes and villains? Of course it is. But not in our brand new The Restis History Book. A History of the World in 51 Heroes and Vos. villains. Now, in this book, we have picked out some of our very favorite characters from the last few years of the rest is history. So we've got Genghis Khan, we have Cyrus the Great, we have Marianne Twainette, and obviously we have Brian Jones of the Rolling Stones. Now, some of these people are friends of the show, some of them are unwanted acquaintances,
历史不仅仅是英雄和恶棍的故事吗？当然不是。但在我们全新的《其余皆是历史》书中，51个英雄和恶棍眼中的世界史。现在，在这本书中，我们挑选了一些我们在过去几年《其余皆是历史》中最喜欢的人物。所以我们有成吉思汗，我们有居鲁士大帝，我们有玛丽·安托瓦内特，显然我们还有滚石乐队的布莱恩·琼斯。现在，这些人中有些是节目的朋友，有些是不受欢迎的熟人，
some of them are downright foes of the show. But we had one rule. They had to be interesting, and there had to be interesting stories about them. So now is your chance to pick aside, to polish your armour, to don your very best First World War General's moustache, and to decide whether you are on the side of the heroes or the villains. A history of the world in 51 heroes and villains is available now. It makes a wonderful Christmas present.
有些甚至是节目的死对头。但我们有一个规则。他们必须是有趣的，并且关于他们必须有有趣的故事。所以现在是你选择立场、擦亮盔甲、戴上你最好的第一次世界大战将军胡子，并决定你是站在英雄一边还是恶棍一边的时候了。《51个英雄和恶棍眼中的世界史》现已上市。它是一份很棒的圣诞礼物。
I cannot recommend it to you more highly. If you don't buy a copy, you will probably regret it until the day you die. Bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我强烈推荐给你。如果你不买一本，你可能会后悔到死的那一天。再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。